question on
I have a question uh representative lab
would you have any problem if we would
follow this up with 540
your other
great because then respecting your time
hey
good morning represent Emerick and and
members of the uh division two finance
committee uh my name is for the record
Rick Ladd I come from Haverhill New
Hampshire and I'm here today to
introduce uh the house bill 364 relative
to Transportation students attending
Career and Technical Education Centers
I handed out some materials to you just
skip over that first sheet I didn't know
how that got in there
however we have approximately 9 700 kids
participating in CTE programs uh here in
the state the majority of those students
participating 7 800 of those students
are in the CTE slash high school so
they're not having to be transported at
all the remainder of those students the
1900 students come from all the
different sending schools that are
sending to our 25 CTE centers and that's
not including the five centers that we
have across the river in Vermont
starting way up at Canaan coming down to
to Bradford going on down the river down
in Norwich Bridal Brattleboro area those
Springfield those that they we send a
number of our students over to Vermont
for Career Technical education but we're
required for tuition monies and of
course the transportation one needs to
get there the second sheet though I I
just for your familiarity you may be
familiar with how we developed the
transportation costs and how we provide
the tuition costs for CTE
the transportation formula is fairly
simple we provide to the schools at the
rate of 10 cents per pupil per mile
that's how schools are identify the
amount of money they will receive from
the state for transportation from their
sending High School to this Center which
is providing the CTE training if in fact
they aren't transported by the school
vehicle at 10 cents per mile they are
afforded 25 cents per mile to juice
their own personal vehicle but that has
to be approved by your local board uh
before that will even happen
some districts find it's cheaper to do
it that way than to run the 66 passenger
yellow bus also some students are
finding that for example in my neck of
the woods where they go from Haverhill
Woods Woodsville area down to Bradford
which is Oxbow over in Vermont they
oftentimes have work right there in
Bradford following up on their CTE they
just had so they can't get back and then
on the bus and then that so they drive
their own vehicle and and ties in with
an internship program from the CTE
Center
but the tuition part is also very much
linked to this seeing that we
appropriate nine million dollars a year
for tuition and transportation CT that's
what's been done for centuries around
here and uh once you elevate that cost
according to federal law you're stuck
with that elevated cost you can't go
back down to a lesser amount
but the tuition is is much different
because it comes out of the same formula
the first thing we do is we pay off the
transportation costs
out of that nine million bucks so boom
there goes seven hundred thousand
dollars six hundred and eighty thousand
to seven hundred thousand dollars that's
transportation and that's not fully
funding where we need that's not the
actual cost of Transportation the actual
cost of transportation for these
districts you'd have to add in another
2.2 million dollars to it be above
roughly around 2.8 million dollars for
actual Transportation costs
the tuition though is where we have to
deal with the remainder of the 8 million
plus dollars that's left in that pot
after two Transportation dollars leave
and it's based upon the formula you see
in the top of the page there we look at
each district looks at their uh the the
receiving District looks at their doe 25
form and what's the what's the per pupil
cost for providing education in that
High School let's say it's twenty
thousand dollars
then they take a percentage and it's a
multiplier that's between 20 and 40
percent you can look at the sheet below
this one right here you can see how that
filters out in terms of what percentage
various schools are using and that's a
decision of the local receiving school
they make that decision
then we also have a figure of three
percent which is a differential uh per
RSA 188 e for capital reserve fund to
support the CTE Center remember that
receiving School the the one that's
hosting the CTE program doesn't receive
the monies that we're talking about in
this formula so they have through their
operating budget provide the Staffing
and all the associated needs to operate
that CTE Center so there are permitted
within this formula here to add that
three percent differential which can go
towards a future needs in terms of
running that particular Center
uh in transportation
um we we provide the amount that I
mentioned the 10 cents per mile per
pupil or the 25 cents but in tuition the
state pays for 75 uh of the the costs
but if there's more people transporting
now then and there are seeing that this
last year or so we enabled Nashua Exeter
and Manchester who are transporting
within their school district to a center
the law used to say that if you're
transporting to a receiving uh School
District CTE program you will receive
the transfer the the transportation we
changed that law so if you're in
Manchester and you're shipping kids five
miles across the city to a center then
that's a cost and we want kids going
safely on a bus so we put in the formula
now that we also are going to fund these
additional students while an extra and
and Nashua that's going to amount to
another hundred thousand dollars a year
so we have not ever really improved the
amount of money we're providing that's
why we wrote in legislation in priority
years full funding for transportation
and that was passed and set in the law
that's in law right now
so going on down the the I've been
working with the folks out at doe and to
the with the CTE uh advisory Council
which is a very active group that meets
often and does a wonderful job with that
wanting to find out what are the actual
costs associated with transportation
and is this formula the what we have
right now based on the per pupil per
mile adequate the policy committee says
no it's not and we voted unanimously for
this bill to go forward we want to look
at what other states are doing funding
based upon the number of trips made the
type of vehicle used uh it costs a lot
less to run a van than it does a large
school bus
and so in the number of trips made per
day this is a formula used in many many
states and this bill allows for this to
occur after we've worked on this because
Department of Education doesn't have
that data or information at this point
in time we haven't set a mileage rate
for buses or for Vans or for southern
means of transportation that has to be
done policy wise so that's why you'll
see on this bill I don't have it in
front of me a later date for the being
implemented because there's strong
policy decisions which have to be made
and we need to move in that direction 10
cents a mile per pupil just does not cut
it in a district where I am where
they're on the bus for 30 to 40 minutes
just going to CTE Center and because of
this cost of Transportation of Labor the
cost of us the maintenance all that it's
a lot more than 10 cents per mile per
pupil when you only have four six four
to six kids participating and when in
fact they can't have more participating
because they're not receiving adequate
funding for the CTE program from the
formula we have right now so some school
districts are intentionally capping the
number of students the opportunity for
students to go from the sending school
to the receiving Center because they
don't have the funding it's not coming
by way of this formula we have set up
right now
the sheet that you see it says CT
Transportation cost First reimbursement
is from Timberlane Regional School
District when I looked at this and
worked with uh Mr beard over at Jeff
over at the doe and even doing it this
weekend it turns out the money that
they're receiving in Timberline only
pays for 24 percent
of the transportation costs
so if we were to take that same 24
percent and build it over the entire
state budget we are shallow 2.2 million
dollars
in in this you can take that same
formula and work with the tuition as
well on the tuition formula there's
another sheet which is a little older
but you can see that on that spreadsheet
right here in this first page here
that over the course that year where we
were short
in terms why I guess on the the next
page down
uh we were short 2.27 million dollars
that year in providing the actual cost
for transportation you see the actual
loss
which are uh
see that yeah the tuition and
transportation the actual uh tuition
costs were were 10.3 million dollars and
and you're looking at tuition there
we're providing tuition because it's
amortized or as spread out amongst the
number of students participating and
when we have more students there's less
money per pupil coming out of that nine
million dollar pot and so they receive
8.1 million dollars that year they were
shy 2.2 or 2.3 million dollars so
whether you change tuition or you change
Transportation you've got to uh really
increase that amount from 9 million to
11.2 million dollars to make this work
now in the state if you look at our
adequacy formula under the indicators of
what is an adequate education of those
13 indicators four of which are CTE
oriented
now are we providing an adequate
education for these students if we're
having a cap because they're not
receiving the money that is a question
and policy is very very concerned about
are we funding CTE the way we should be
when you compare this state to Delaware
which has similar number of students
where their participation is 50 percent
of their high school kids take at least
one CTE program in our state at 17
percent
and these are the students that come out
of CTE centers where their achievement
scores are higher than the achievement
scores coming out of rigor High School
they're by five percentage points their
CTE gives them a skill they come out
with a skill their their career ready
that's something you don't come out of a
high school with they're employable and
they have purpose and of that 75 percent
of the kids at CTE go on to
post-secondary education so there's all
kinds of reasons why we really need to
really put our sites into this Career
Technical education program
uh it's a program which has a lot of
needs and a lot of issues but it's also
the one educational component that I see
that it's going to really Drive our
Workforce Drive our economy and that's
where we have to have more kids coming
out this Knowledge and Skills how to
perform these jobs when I was down to
Salem uh CTE Center and I was querying
from students where what are you doing
here you're studying what robotics or no
I'm studying medical preparation medical
medicine I said where are you going
young lady and she was a senior so and
this is at the beginning of the senior
year in CTE at The Vocational Center
down there oh I've already been accepted
of Virginia Tech
these students are highly qualified
students we need to have more of our
students attending CTE centers that
means we have to identify what we're
doing with transportation and just
because we have to jump it up maybe two
million dollars we can't go down but
what we have to remember what is the
whole purpose of these centers what is
the purpose what we're here sitting for
today so I'll conclude my presentation
I'm sorry I went on so long with it but
I'm really involved with CTE it's a real
important area which we need to stress
questions Mary
thank you Mr chair and thank you cheer
lad I um agree with you
um
for
as long as I can remember
the rate has been the same in as many
budgets as I've worked on as I can
remember
um
I highly recommend that I hope division
two will look at this with favor and add
to the line to the amount of 11.2
million dollars for this purpose we all
know and it's it's a national
recommendation that more students attend
CTE programs and to encourage them to do
this if this is one way we can do it I
think we should invest in our kids I
have watched students go through these
programs I worked at a school of
technology and I just have just the
highest praise and
not to do this is just unconscionable we
have
I I don't even know how many years it's
been the same amount you have no it's
been there ever since I've been in the
house that's dating myself but I do know
that the benefit of this we had a young
man that graduated from the CTE Center
here in Concord with Steve Rothenberg
went on to White Mountain Community
College majoring in diesel mechanics he
came back and he was hired right on at
Kenworth right here and charged that
program he walked into a job which is a
fantastic opportunity I'm seeing that
from uh Mr frawworth who who's also a
director down south of us and with Chris
Dodge down in Salem and up on the Lakes
Region these directors are very much in
tune in working with programs that are
going to benefit this state we are also
using instructors within there that
maybe not don't have the teacher
certification but they come highly
trained for example from a Napa
technology program or Toyota and we are
getting funding support from Toyota from
GMC from Ford we have certain centers
that are they're driving home not
driving but they are they're they're
dealing with auto mechanics and that and
they're substitis quite thoroughly by by
the New Hampshire automobile deal
Dealers Association so there's a lot to
it there's a lot of business groups
which are anxious to see this occur I
would say if you asked me where is our
number one or number two priority and
this is one of them this is it again
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Vlad for taking the
questions first I want to say that
having taught the equivalent of CD
classes for over a decade for a living
you know it was a Microsoft certified
trainer and whatnot I highly value those
that type of training and I think it's a
very valuable way to you know get use
useful job skills to our students I'm
just trying to understand a little bit
more the impact of this particular bill
I looked at the you know current chapter
and the weight is representing and it
seems that the major changes that we
want to move away from
reimbursing based on the number of
students that get transportations and
just base this on the vehicle would that
be well the vehicle a number of trips
correct I mean yeah that's right so
basically we removed the counting of how
many kids are in a van we just base it
on the number of trips with a van and
the mileage rates yeah and there are
several components there within this
that legislation comes from uh some of
their Midwestern states from Colorado
and other places yes my concern that I
would appreciate if you would address is
that right now because we base the
funding formula based on the number of
children and again we could just tweak
the reimbursement rate and you know
leave the law in place to achieve more
funding
my concern is that by removing that you
may unintentionally remove an incentive
for the school districts to be as
effective as possible in selecting the
vehicle that they are using basically
you would reimburse the same this
formula will reimburse the same if we
send one school bus with one student
inside
that's why in the bill itself you'll see
that we're trying to get away from this
formula uh policy wise but it's going to
takes time with the department and the
CTE director working with getting the
information in from these school
districts regarding
Transportation costing and and the
reimbursement for a van would be based
upon the miles that's gotten in the van
CBD number trips miles taken type of
vehicle rather than
as you if you as you've identified on
the per pupil basis which uh it does
make a whole lot of sense when we're
talking about trying to uh increase the
number of kids which are attending uh
the CTE centers and in many districts
are having to contract that service with
the bus transportation company whether
it's first student or Durham or some
other outfit and they're running huge
buses and that's what the contract is
charging us I think we can reduce and
save money by moving to a new formula to
support more kid kids going to the
centers I I just one last follow-up very
quickly
to me when I look at the current bill
you know your policy goal is to
incentivize you know more kids going
there to me it seems that by paying
based on the number of students you are
giving the schools an incentive to
increase the number of kids in the
school bus while just basing it on the
trip would make it neutral to the school
you know you get the same reimbursement
whether it's one kid or more I'm just
trying to understand your thoughts on
this potential issue it's it's due to
the fact that we have in that nine
million dollars that same nine million
dollars is used for both transportation
and tuition it's locked together
so if you increase your transportation
costs you're decreasing the amount of
money available for tuition and so
therefore you're eliminating kids from
participating in the program
uh and and and by doing that
um we are locked that that formula is
locking Us in this this process so one
way around that is to one change the
reimbursement formula for transportation
but also to include that money into that
nine million dollars so that when for
example we now are counting kids which
are transported from Exeter from
Nashville and from Manchester that is
reduce the amount of money it's
available for tuition and so then the
school district of May at one time
received X number of dollars is now
they're receiving x minus you know the
the the result of the three districts
which are now involved we're also uh
involving kids now in grades 10 11 and
12 and so that's an expansion of the
program so we're our numbers we're
trying to increase but what's
restricting us is the financial support
being given to this program it does
restrict and it turns out to end up
being a 91a issue with the local school
districts it's unfunded mandate simply
because every student deserves the
opportunity to attend and when you say
as a district well we can't send anymore
because we don't have any more money are
you then having to flip a coin as to who
goes or who doesn't go that is not in
accordance with an adequate education
thank you you're welcome Ken
thank you Mr chairman thank you chairman
Ladd your testimony appears to say we
need 2.2 million in this budget we're
working on now but the effective date on
this bill is July 1st 2025 so is it two
different things here one is give me 2.2
million in the budget you're working on
and change the formula for the next by
any means you you're reading it
oh thank you Mr directly
and uh thank you for taking my question
you worked very hard at education
problems here my question is um have you
ever seen any studies as to how many
kids and CTE go on to post-secondary
education yep yep we have 75 percent of
those so it takes 75 percent of your 10
000 kids those are the kids going in the
post-secondary education many of them
choose the community college system
where they're refining those skills but
because of the degree of technical
difficulty presented at CTE centers now
some are opting to go right to the
Virginia tax of the world and and clean
it up there so this is a program that I
highly recommend it's and I highly you
know uh
encourage you to visit one of our CTE
centers you're going to see things that
you once only saw at the University
level
okay thank you Mr chair and thanks to
chair Weiler for asking three of my
questions
the one question that I have remaining
is that what group is looking at the
formula and when that formula is revised
does that need legislation will that be
coming back as legislation or are you
I I think where where you are and now
you're we made the policy decision down
in policy recognizing and having that
impact it's now up to you right here to
identify to look at the funding issue
which we have a severe funding issue
here but also then to move Statute in
accordance to support that uh so I think
that can be done through your hb2
legislation
um and the money in the HP one uh
there's where it needs to happen and uh
I hope you do it
oh if we get this in hb2 can the policy
can this be effective before 2025 does
that make sense I mean we're putting in
this money now to cover the the
difference between the 9 and 11. these
are the two components that
representative Myler was just
referencing there's really two issues on
the table right now one that 2.2 million
and this was identified when uh a number
of us have been on the advisory Council
in fact that's where uh representative
umberger was last year and we all
recognized we had to get that 2.2
million dollars just to sustain what
we're doing right now properly and to
get more students involved the second
part of this is dealing with the tuition
Transportation formula and that can't be
initiated for several years seeing that
we as representative Weiler noted there
it's going to take some work we just
don't want to open up something and then
be going down some kind of a rabbit hole
and not having things done properly we
want to make sure this is done
absolutely correctly we do know that
many states are really doing this well
as a result of changing the formula from
a per pupil type formula which we've had
for over a decade to what is something
that's more reasonable and and really
goes in the path of getting more
okay
so Mr chair would you accept a motion
um to approve
chair Lads request for 2.2 million in
each year of the biennium for TNT and
for hb2 to um adopt the formula change
would you accept that what about this
bill
okay
all right
all right we have a second
motion made and second here are you
ready
it's making me do this by a show of
hands all those in favor
don't
okay moving on to 5 40. thank you thank
you Rick you're welcome Ken
I will say you're an excellent advocate
for
hey I I tell you if I had children in my
household right now I'd aim them in that
direction there's no question when I saw
that young man now working at Kenworth
earning over 80 000 a year
starting right
and enjoying what he's doing
okay well open the hearing on House Bill
540.
well thank you very much uh
representative Emrick and members of the
uh at division two uh finance committee
this one's not quite as easy
um uh but it's uh
it's again another bill that came out of
uh education policy unanimously
we're looking at the formula here and
you're familiar with the adequacy
formula and you know that there's that
component within differentiated Aid
which deals with special education
we have had uh much testimony
that and I in fact had a meeting last
night that started at approximately 5 30
drove home stopped at the Warren Village
door at store school and
um ended up speaking with the principal
of that school for until 7 7 15 at night
and it was all over
this portion of adequacy special
education costs
now we have 39 States within the country
right now that are looking at that
identify a process or funding
differentiated AIDS special education
using a weighted formula we have one
formula which we use for differentiated
Aid regardless and there's a sheet which
you have there you might look at first
that says special education 13
disability categories on the bottom of
those are the 13 areas according to
federal law and New Hampshire Rule and
New Hampshire law which we identify
students who may have a special
education disability
and you can see from the top you go from
developmental delay to specific learning
disabilities like in the area of a a
reading or language arts or mathematics
where you see such a discrepancy between
certain areas in learning I won't get
into that to keep my principal ship back
behind me here and did you see some
other areas like orthopedically
handicapped or tranic brain injury
um some severe type handicapping
conditions
when we're providing in our formula and
differentiate Aid approximately two
thousand dollars for each student that
has an IEP
we know that there's some IEPs for
example a few of a student receiving
Speech Pathology or speech therapy and
the issue is they have that R problem
you know they're from New England it's
an articulation issue and so
um or they have other articulation
issues just not the r because the r is
part of what we are
um but
um the issue is that student may have
only a need to meet with a speech
pathologist or somebody delivering that
service for a half hour twice a week
however we have other students that are
needing toilting they may be a mute they
may have disability from traumatic brain
injury they may have you know an
intellectual disability where they need
constant work
the need not just accommodation they
need modification a program those are
terms within special education law
so what we're looking at in this bill
here is having three category areas and
you can also see I provided you a sheet
and unfortunately had somebody scribble
on it but this is a sheet which is
required underneath the uh
idea Part B where we notify the Feds
that we have students that require more
than 80 percent of a day to have special
education services
we know that those students which are
below 80 percent that require less time
than the 80 or more and we also know
that we have students that are placed in
hospital situations or residential
placements uh which can be very costly
that we we support that through our
catastrophic Aid or what we call special
education Aid now where you you're
familiar with the formula where it's
three and a half times you have to pay
for us if you're not under the special
education Aid the responsibility for you
as a school district to pay for the
special education costs are for the
three first three and a half times the
average per pupil cost and if the
average cost per year is twenty thousand
dollars you're gonna have to Fork out
twenty seventy thousand dollars before
you're going to get any support from the
state other than what's in
differentiated that two thousand dollars
once you get beyond the three and a half
mark up to ten times that average cost
per pupil the state sets in and pays 80
percent of that
so this District's still on the hook for
the twenty percent twenty twenty percent
of that once you get back Beyond ten
times the state pays that different that
the rest of it
those costs are extremely extremely
costly I've had one District I sat in
with a speaker of the house this last
summer where the school board was up in
the office there across the street
saying we're short 1.5 million dollars
in special education and we've looked
everywhere and we're having now taken
out of the operational side of the
budget in other areas and that's
subtracting from another area
programming
so what we have here is a need to
recognize in our Even in our base
adequacy formula that there are
differences between these IEPs in terms
of what is needed last year when you
passed the extraordinary needs Grant
um we tacked on and and education policy
another 14 million dollars based upon a
formula which had these weighted
components for special educate education
Aid we did it not the way we're doing
here we did it by saying well we think
that the first three categories cost
this much the next three that but
there's a lot of overage between these
categories it's a wrong way of doing it
we determine that the best way to time
needed from staff and services during
the course of a day
so if they're over 80 percent they're
big time needs there in terms of Finance
to support that disability and that
child
so what this does it UPS the ante as far
as you can see on this sheet right here
and this right here there's two sheets
which you may have here
the first one is what we did last year
and we were told that of our special
education students there's 30 309 kids
in this state with IEPs out of our 164
okay there's thirty thousand plus
students that have IEPs in this state
we have a total of course around what
164 000 give or take students in the
state so there's uh increasing number of
students that number has been at that
level
for our last 10 years but our
demographic mistake
has gone the opposite direction from uh
two hundred and ten thousand students in
the last 10 years to now the 160 Plus
however our student education population
in special education has not decreased
in numbers in fact stayed somewhat
stable
and at that but it says there's a higher
incidence of special education amongst
our students than there was back 10
years ago
so we're looking now at trying to figure
out how to fund that and the first sheet
shows you know the percentages we had in
numbers that we were given last year by
the department we had of those that are
in category a that be the category of
less than 80 percent of the time there
were 26 825 three students in the next
category those which were more than
eight eighty percent time it was seven
or two thousand seven hundred and twenty
eight students and those that are in
residential placements or Hospital
placements or other placements as
described on this sheet right here from
the Feds that you have
um were uh more uh more much more costly
that it was 2.5 percent of our student
population we have since been told by
Finance people at uh at the department
that these figures are more accurate
so so they look to me to be more
approximations as well but they're all
parking and I guess uh we're looking at
of the thirty thousand six hundred
students twenty three thousand the
category a b seven thousand students and
C 600 students so 600 are the most needy
students that are going to places like
Beckett Beckett uh school or being
placed out of state even still so lastly
the additional cost to support this
program would be 21 million dollars
doing it the way we did last year it
cost around 14 million dollars but that
is a figure that you're you two you
would have to look at uh however if you
look at the study Commission
which we had
a year and a half ago uh that commission
look at the weighted formula and I did
agree with the weighted portions I
didn't agree necessarily with what kind
of a value they were giving to
weightedness it was 4.19 of the base
adequacy figure our base attic squeeze
four thousand dollars so you go four
times four you're seeing you're already
up to sixteen thousand dollars right
there uh for what would have been
differentiated eight if you look at this
formula right here and we're looking at
a costing uh two thousand dollars which
that is our present formula for
differentiated a that's what you'll be
looking at for FY 23.
category B is 4729 so that's a little
bit more than what base adequacy is so
we're at a factor of one point something
and if you look at category C what
that's the residential placements within
differentiated Aid you're looking at
approximately a 1.5
so a base adequacy so and compared to
those other 39 States in this country
this is very low of what we're doing to
support special education this is why
you're seeing so many towns saying now
like a Paramount that's just south of me
the budget they're looking at this year
is 22 percent higher than it was last
year simply because of what they're
receiving special education and they're
of course inflationary costs and
operational costs are also going up
there's a lot of rationale for it but
then as I drove through Warren this
morning I saw a sign out front come to
our meeting on Thursday night we are
looking at the discrepancies between
what we're asked to do what we're told
we have to do and what we're able to
raise locally through our property taxes
so this federal government when they put
special education in place said we are
going to fund you at 40 percent level
we're down West around 16 right now at
best
and what we've created is a 91a issue no
in it's happening and so what are we
going to do to try to show that through
our adequacy formula we are working to
try to help share that burden we're
going to contribute to it so that's why
you see this bill coming forward we are
recommending from policy that a weighted
version of supporting special education
be applied to the differentiated
component of of adequacy formula thank
you
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
for taking the questions I'm trying to
understand why category B swings so much
if you look at the handout on you know
the top of the first page the number of
special education pupils in category B
on the left side is 2728 on the right
side is about seven thousand that when
originally viewing that I thought it was
a change in the formula you said it's
just a different estimate I would
appreciate an explanation that's what we
got from the Department evidently
they're saying that they have more kids
that you see the numbers come out of a
category a where it goes from 26 to 23.
so it's that I would say these figures
um I would look at the spreadsheets
you're going to get from them in terms
of special education differentiated Aid
you'll see the number of students
they're planning for then I would ask
the question of them how does that break
down in terms of this formula right here
that you're responsible for
in terms of
that federal law idea because that
breakdown has to be figured out how many
students are in a how many RMB how many
are in C these are the figures I've been
able to get to this point we're working
on figures which we got I got from the
director uh about half three quarters of
a year ago and then when we were
dealing with this bill in the hearings
this year it was a notified to us that
the figures have changed and we have
these approximations for you so I would
say you need to do a little bit of
research yourselves on this to make sure
you're getting accurate figures the
whole concept though and the principle
behind this is we need to have a
weighted formula that's more supportive
of what we're doing out in the field
don't worry we just started with the
questions on this one but I appreciate
your information obviously we'll follow
up in a lot of detail because that's
still a humongous jump in a number that
as you were saying for 10 years has been
more or less flat at the total when
suddenly I'm told the category more than
doubles but I think we need to look into
it right if you look at Aid
re-categorizing it's not the number of
students it's just how they're sliding
between percent yeah
take care
so when I saw this number 2079 and I
thought where have I read that before
and so I'm looking in hb2
and
find it on I think now I split the pages
65.
where nope that's not it
but it's it's one the governor assigned
in in hb2 the 2079 was already an
increase he put in I don't know whether
you gave it to him or he figured it out
but
um
he put that in there so that 55 million
times 2079 is already in hb2 that that
is correct 2000 the the amount of money
that you should have seen for
2079 bucks and so much sense that that
is the figure which you've had for
differentiated just based upon the
adjustments that we give that formula
based on CPI uh so okay from year to
from every two years so then when we go
we go to category B and C which he did
not include we would have to subtract
the four thousand the 2079 from the 4729
times
2728 pupils and the category C you'd
subtract the 2079
from the six thousand two thirty nine
times
uh 758 pupil to figure out
the extra cost that we're talking about
that's correct representative but a lot
of it is already in hb2 that's my point
as part of adequacy it's it's there uh
we're just looking at a policy change in
terms of how we do support that category
uh the policy committee believes
strongly that there's such a difference
between these 13 IEP categories that you
see here and the amount of time and the
amount of dollars required to deliver
that service some of that can provide
right by the resource room teacher uh
you know when you're talking about
specific learning disability but there's
others which are really challenging in
terms of costs and the differentiated
Aid
does not support that the way we really
should
thank you Mr chair thank you chairman
LED um just a question
um
who will make the determination will be
at the local at the Lea level and will
the Lea report out costs per child for
special education and then the
determination of the category will be
made that way
um how would we do this
the course the IEPs put together at the
local level right and you have your
Specialists and your Administration
participating in that along with the
parent
and the decisions made that Susan needs
an IEP and you identify the services
which are going to be provided
some people have asked me
represent Ladd are they going to really
try to stack the deck and and put more
people in this category than that
category I think that that would be a
dreadful error
um and especially when the area of
special education is one that's
seriously looked at and litigated also
within the iepss you identify the number
of services provided to this student in
that categorical area each day or each
week and it's sometimes to say it's uh
you're going to have a Speech Pathology
twice a week well that obviously is one
that's eighty percent or less so the IEP
will identify that when the IEPs are
then direct as sent to the at that
information is sent to the Department of
Education by the directors down in the
school districts then it is Consolidated
and that's where we come up with the
aggregate information
oh the follow-up would be with regard to
our Charter Schools
um because the Lea continues to be
responsible for the cost of special
education
um so sometimes there are extraordinary
costs just for transportation and just
because of the nature that they're in
different locations and needs a
different
um how will that be played out
well that cost is now reflected in the
the budget that that uh the school
that's providing the services receives
those dollars right now the uh the
charter school does not receive that
money that's one area within
differentiated Aid it goes to the
they're providing Public School
but that again my understanding would be
then that all factors would be for a
child within a charter who has a
disability in an IEP all those factors
would be identified all costs would be
identified in the IEP for that child
that's correct and the determination
would be made at that point in time
when that IAP is signed that's when it's
made those determinations by the parent
so this particular bill is as much a
policy
change that as it is dollars I would say
it's both uh you're you're impacting
you're you're looking at your adequacy
formula but you're also looking the
policy in which generates these those
changes in your your formula
so it's a combination of both but
but it's set all it said in the
parameters
I mean the ABC yeah you're just kind of
defining here what here's what yes we're
establishing the weighted categories for
them receiving the amount that's
appropriate and differentiated eight
okay question yeah I just wanted to
follow up on what you are saying so the
policy part of this obviously is
determining that instead of just one
blanket level we want to have three
differentiated level and describing the
ways that kids are put into ABC right
and then
the finance part is obviously figuring
out how much money we can uh you know
put in there because that's gonna be a
decision that will take more work than
we can do this morning so I think you
know I would suggest but not make the
motion yet but I would suggest that I'm
leaning towards retaining this so that
we can continue working on it once
everybody is ready for a motion
Mary I would make that motion to retain
house bill 540.
great second
motion made in second account
I don't know if Mickey was doing the
same figures I'm doing
I'm using 2079 which is in
hb2
times all these students then I go to
the two categories and add the
differences and I come up with an extra
10 million
10 million three
it's not about what you came up so
compared to so working off of the
governor's recommended budget at this
point adequacy this bill is about 12
million dollars a year above the funding
level in here all right I came up with
10. we came up with 10-2 when we were
playing with these figures last year
with representative Hennessey
which you know that's
we'll find it
anyway I just was running the figures
what I'm doing is subtracting 20079 from
the
4729 and also from the six thousand two
thirty nine times the number of students
you came up with 12
yeah there's some I mean we can get into
this later when we talk about it but
anyway I don't have spreadsheets with me
that's what I'm seeing as as the class
to to meet these criteria anyway just
thought I'd point that out while we're
busy here doing numbers thank you Mr
chair uh question do we need to retain
this or can we add this into hb2 once we
figured out the the additional amount
that we need as we just did with the
if um we are all agreeable
um I believe that we are agreeable
if that makes sense to you
the motion of course right now is truly
tank
um and I would withdraw my motion okay
and my new motion no Nikki's telling me
I just want to remind everyone where we
are with the process we have to do a
recommendation on these bills so we have
to Circle back probably to 364. and
actually make a retain motion which we
didn't a motion of uh
just adding it to the budget where I
think we'll retain and then as we do our
budget work similarly to our 10 prior
bills when we get into a budget work
session we'll work on House Bill one and
two changes so I think what I'm hearing
thank you thank you Mickey all in favor
of retaining
okay unanimous
thank you all right thank you
uh next up and Mr chair you may just
want to confirm that with 364 the first
bill we had today it you are retaining
that bill uh I believe the plan is to
include the language although it it
doesn't take effect until fiscal 26
which is beyond this upcoming biennial
budget and that section doesn't have a
direct Financial impact so it's up to
you and the committee if you want to
pass that bill
on its own and then make the increase in
the line item for tuition and
transportation the 2.2 million we passed
the bill
okay I I thought the plan was to
incorporate the bill in the house but we
said agb2 so right now the motion is to
adopt including hb2 I think what Meek is
saying is that we either pass it
independently and send it back to the
floor or we retain it to include it in
hb2 I don't is it what you're saying
that you cannot really adopt but they
say HB to either retain an hb2 or adopt
and send to the floor yes you just want
to be clear with what are you doing with
House Bill 364 are you passing this back
are you going to retain it and just keep
it in this committee and put the
language in-house Bill too I think I
which I mean either way I mean whatever
the committee play right so I think
right
yeah the the 2.2 million we're talking
about for tuition and transportation
that'll be a house bill one amendment in
the line item for that so that would be
taken care of for 24 and 25 when we do
budget work but this bill would be
separate of that and that wouldn't this
wouldn't take effect until fiscal 26 so
you could pass this policy separate and
keep it out of house bill too as an
option
I think actually the original motion
said adopt but we also said hb2 so if we
would be well willing to clarify that
well no we adopted the bill right but we
agreed that we're going to put the money
in hb2 right the money HP one so so you
may just want to clarify your motion on
this is OTP on 365. yeah and then that
way it'll go back to the full committee
with that recommendation and pass over
to the Senate you know on 364 the first
bill correct so you were the motion I
will make my motion to OTP okay
it was made in we it was unanimous both
right so but we all agree that this is
an OTP and we'll talk about the numbers
but the language is just OTP got it okay
moving right along
so this bill I I handed everyone a
revised fiscal note
that uh based on the amendment the
department is saying there is no
estimated cost associated with this bill
any longer now this is the bill that's
relative to the department providing uh
the House and Senate standing committees
on education with laws and rules and a
format that uh that's comply that would
comply with this bill and they're saying
they can do it with no cost
can we ask the department to come
um if anybody has any questions Diane
oh it was it was on
I always mess that up
good morning for the record my name is
Diana Fenton I'm an attorney with the
Department of Education
I'm happy to answer any questions this
Mr chair yes
may I ask questions absolutely thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question isn't this a usual and
customary practice that the department
of Ed has always done this it it is
thank you for the question you're
absolutely right uh certainly you know
the department better than I do
um we have we have in the past
um provided that I think that was
um done with minor Shannon is it was
done with discretionary funds and then
when um under commercial edelblute he
removed those discretionary funds and so
we have not been providing that we have
been providing um the information on a
flash drive it's on our website there
are other ways to access it
that being said however everyone who
knows me knows that I love the books I
love the paper copies I carry one around
with me in my car so uh every time this
issue comes up I can certainly
understand the legislature's desire to
have it in in paper copy
I would agree I'm we all have little
stickies aren't our law books
um I personally could never have lived
without my law book I continue to like
to have a book in my hand and I know the
education committee really likes that as
well
so this Bill is saying that um
this would require the Department of
Education to do this yeah um but does
does it specify that it is in hard copy
not technology wise
I I don't I have the amended fiscal note
in front of me
um I do now I have the pillow in front
of me he is so good
um
storage device
It also says a physical copy of okay a
copy on a portable data storage device
or
that's a series with an Orient right so
it's either of the three should meet the
legal requirement
So based on your input and I don't want
to put it on you because I'll add myself
to the list
that we would like that maybe we need a
shell
um that the department shall provide
a hard copy
and for those who wish to have the thumb
drive they can obtain that but for
members of the committee and the
department members who use it for their
work purposes that a hard copy be
provided
I think that
I think that was and I'm not here to
speak for representative Tanner
obviously but um my understanding
because this bill has been brought
forward
yes oh yay I was going to say
representative Tanner would you like to
sit in on your bill
good
Tanner is here I don't think on her
behalf but my uh this bill has come
before this committee um this bill has
been brought forward previously and and
again uh representative Tanner is here
but my understanding in speaking with
representative Tanner is the
the intent is to have the hard copies of
the actual book and uh to Echo
representative Hughes um question that
is a prior practice of the department if
that language were to be put in here as
an amendment the fiscal note would
change and so the department
is
the Department's rule is to comply with
the law and so if the law says to
provide a copy of the book The
department will do so
but we'll need the the money to to do
that we'll need an appropriation in
order to effectuate that so
the department understands the history
of this practice the department
recognizes the importance of this
practice but if that language were to be
implemented the fiscal note would
subsequently change
thank you Mr chair just a quick question
I mean right now this bill is coming up
the out of the policy committee as is
with the you know amendments and whatnot
I if the policy committee is comfortable
with this language I personally don't
see why you know we would Tinker with
that but just to understand you know
what the law says right now if somebody
would prefer one of the three options
would they be able to ask for their
preferred option or the with the
Department of Education say we have a
website go search on the website anytime
so I'm just trying to understand your
interpretation on how this law would
require the Department of Education to
uh act on this well I will defer your
question on the language that is before
you from the policy committee I will
defer to representative I'll be happy to
tell you is that
the the practice as representative Heath
alluded to did change dramatically from
providing the actual law book to the
members of the committee to saying the
information is available on our website
or available on a flash drive the books
were not available they are available to
members of the department so I have one
and every year causes great jealousy as
I walk through the Halls
um but they are not available to the
committee members and so we have those
those other options
um
the flash drive the the website
um but but there is no option I got it
thank you Mary just to reiterate then
what I think I'm hearing you say it has
been past practice
for many many many many years as long as
I can remember that the Department of
the education committee
and those department members that needed
copies of the law book with copies and I
believe it was charged to their regular
line of operation it was came out of
their
or else they just were provided with
copies
well anyway it was just past practice
and that past practice with the current
Administration has shifted
so that is the purpose of that of this
bill is that my understanding
yes okay thank you that is the shortest
answer from a lawyer that has ever been
requested I convinced I would just wear
it thank you thank you so uh yes you
were correct
any other questions oh yeah I'm looking
at the the page that's the fiscal note
and it shows a 53 56 000 however it
shows
424 copies
to the House and Senate of the drive and
424 copies of the book
I don't think nearly that many need to
be distributed to the house maybe 28 to
the Senate maybe 10 or 15. but you know
it's going to be a lot fewer than
424 more most people in the house will
never even open the book
I think that was based on a prior
version
um and I I did speak with represent
representative Tanner of that um about
that I think the the bill has been
amended uh has changed and I I agree
with you
um that the idea the intent is to
provide it to the policy committee and
it would be far fewer
um
are we are we talking about that big
book that hit the deck a couple weeks
ago
can that be printed on demand
I mean uh anybody have knowledge of this
I know there are copy machines being
used commercially now where books can be
printed on demand they don't inventory
oh I know I've seen very thick book
especially with the annotations
um
I I do know that and again I I hesitate
to speak for representative Tanner I'm
getting nervous here
um I know representative Tanner and I
and if you'd like to join me you're
welcome to please do
we have talked at length about this
issue I know that she's spent a lot of
time talking to the publisher which is
very admirable
um and I know last year there were some
concerns about the longevity of the
ability for the publisher Thomas Reuters
to continue to publish the book
um
but I don't have any personal knowledge
of that what I do know is that we're
still able to have a physical copy I
have a physical copy of the members of
the Department of Education has that as
well
um I'm going to stop talking for you now
okay
um yes I I first of all I want to
reiterate that this came out of
committee twenty to zero and that
um the people in my committee education
committee
guard those books like they're gold I
mean one person told me that during
vacation they took it home and has
started reading it front to back so and
it used to be
um really really thick when Joe was on
the committee really thick and then they
narrowed it down to just particularly
education laws the thickness of the book
had references to the exact uh camps
Sports Camps that had to have some
educational laws affecting them and they
took those out so just had it there so
what happened was
back up a term
not this term but the last term
all of a sudden for no particular reason
we had no books uh coming back meeting
in person and so I started this search
and put in the bill and was sitting like
this when a big box came over with the
with the books that we were told we
couldn't get
um but pretty effective yes happened
again this year uh because the the bill
was uh tabled in the Senate last time
this year putting in the same bill boom
it happened not while I was doing my
testimony but
before when I came to you know to the
room so
um that was kind of odd and then I
noticed Diana had her books
um also so the books are available and
they're annotated uh which is fantastic
like today we had a question on
background checks which I wish you had
been there for but The annotation goes
back and and tells when bills were
changed and why they were changed and
even some court cases that were on them
I'm a I'm a retired teacher I don't when
I came down here I knew nothing about
law I don't know you know I've picked up
the now on Jeopardy I even know some of
the law questions but
um you know I need that book
I need that book to be able to do my job
and that's why this this is in and so we
got the got the thing from the
Department of Ed with this 58 000 and
I'm saying wow I you know just can't
imagine that it costs I I expected maybe
right but it's it may even be nothing I
mean it may be comped uh to the state I
haven't worked my way through there but
the state of New Hampshire uh you know
every one of our offices or have even
the the rooms have all the bound books
of all the laws and up and upstairs they
have that and that's where they make
most of their money
um so anyway and I tried to find out
where it was printed and when I went to
Reuters Thomas Reuters I I went through
sales person I went to Publications
persons I you know went through all
these things and nobody knew anything
about these books so I almost got a uh
feeling that it was published or printed
locally and I know that the the state
actually has their own printing
um Department printing firm I called
there and I got pushed around a little
bit and then they said they'd get back
to me and they never got back to me so
who knows right now where where it's at
but anyway
how important these bills are could you
just help me find the printer that you
are talking about I I try to look up
Thomas Ruger and I couldn't find the
printer with that name routers routers
are you oh Reuters Reuters there you go
sorry I completely misunderstood thank
you yep yep
and it's um is it Westfall is the west
west law that is also connected with
that I think they're a company that's
totally together because sometime I got
switched on to them as well
if anybody had the book who could look
on the
I should have brought it with me I
actually snuck out of my committee
because we're voting on things today
yeah thank you Mr chair can we just go
back to the 424 because I don't want one
you know I'm not gonna need it
um what can we do what do you need for
you all to do your work there without
you know people like me who would right
not even that was not the intention of
that bill at all so what would your
intention be what would you like the the
intention was that everybody on House
Education and Senate education got the
book and got it at this when they first
were assigned to the committee right
that's what it says in the bill and that
I would assume I and it's terrible to
assume on legislation but that if the
finance department
section two division two which you deal
with education laws that perhaps you
might want them as well
um
but I that would be something that I
would think that you would have to
this one was very self-serving so I just
did it for myself yeah just a follow-up
that was my question of responsible for
Education because there are a number of
committees who would say we have some
responsibility towards education uh
Judiciary perhaps might have some you
know may have a bill where they would
want reference to that so this is where
I was confused that it wasn't clear to
me that it was only the education
committees especially when it was 424 of
them right so that was the clarification
I was looking for and this book if you
go to the education committee you'll see
it on the table with most of the people
and mine has sticky notes in it um
chairman Lads has sticky notes all over
it uh all Caitlyn and and Diana have
sticky notes as well oh thank you yeah
that's his and you can see there's some
sticky notes but not as much as mine but
um identified in the front of the book
and
um
you know when when people come in to
testify or today when we're working on
executing and we had a bill on
background checks which I've worked a
lot on I could immediately turn to 189
and and see it if I had a computer which
I have and a little iPad it takes me you
know I have to go through this this and
this and I get to
um a law reference that doesn't have
annotations and and I have to know the
specific chapter and verse of it in
order to find it
here I can just read through it yes
thank you Mr chair so
if we would uh Tinker with the language
of the bill to make it uh you know a bit
more specific in terms of how many
copies of the book would be required say
you know you've got 20 people on the
education committee say another seven or
eight in various leadership you know
positions and the Senate education
committee and maybe Finance too would
you
feel that that you know fulfills the
spirit of your bill because as you know
the sponsor I want to make sure that I
understand what the intent is would that
be compatible consistent with what you
were trying to do I definitely I mean my
like I said mine was purely self-serving
uh to start out with and then all of a
sudden grew to 424 which I didn't have
any idea how that happened but you know
I think uh for example Judiciary uh
probably doesn't deal with education in
the depth that our committee and the
senate committee in your committee does
where we on a daily basis we're actually
looking at these laws for them they're
they're uh
committee resource person could probably
you know they could say to them could
you look up the you know the laws for
this specific Bill and it would only
happen a few times maybe uh in terms I
got it thank you and by the way see you
testify on this and begin a book shows
up
thank you same thing
book fairy you know just it happens
it did didn't it
thank you Mr chair and thank you Linda
for taking my representative for taking
my questions
um I have to say I am
a little disgruntled that we have to
create a bill
for people to get for the education
committee to get their law book and for
members of the Department of Education
um I just want to have that noted for
the record
um because I find it very disturbing
that a precedent that has been in place
for probably
as many years as the Department of
Education has been there um and it just
seemed like a logical thing that people
need and when I talk to OLS they didn't
he didn't seem to know what I was
talking about he said oh yeah I've got
them all here they're going right over
um and I so I don't understand so I'm
troubled by that but I would certainly
be happy to support this thank you very
much
and thank you and I I just want to also
point out that you know in in years past
because this is my fifth term
um we've also had a lot more support
from having a secretary uh you know or a
resource person just for education I
mean we've got over 100 bills this year
and it's hard that they're cutting back
on Staffing and um you know I feel sorry
for Gen 4 and it's I I almost feel very
hesitant asking her to do research
because she's got so much honor plate
from different committees so
this helps everybody else
one thing leads to another right well
thank you thank you for letting me
so
I almost that's what I was going to say
or a hundred I mean just put it on 50.
you need to say 10 bucks
oh
well it's 112. right but if some other
reps it gee I'd be interested and you
say give me 10 bucks right
but if it's free I'll take it they need
a store a door stop I'll donate a brick
um well my my question was
well I don't want to no
it would seem to me that people by
printing for the state know who got on
demand publishing capabilities so I
testimony we heard was it came from a
discretionary fund which got eliminated
so that's the reason but there's still a
line item for publishing or printing or
and they still send one to every
superintendent
is oh really that's what I heard
and that's what's in here is it
appropriate to have a this would just be
I guess an amendment that has no money
attached to it to say that the
Department of Education will provide
this Senate and House Education
committees with the laws and is that am
I going to get you know this um pillar
read because that's an unfunded mandate
or can we just say that the Department
of Education
should provide them with a with a book
that they could they can find fifty
thousand huh yeah but now I would
suggest if that's appropriate well I
think that's what this is
I mean that's that's basically what this
says
but
okay
it didn't need to come here in its
current form because right now the
department can provide those laws
through the flash drive or you know
online stuff without an expense I think
the reason why it still ended up here
besides the fact it had an offend was
that
you know we are right now being
basically asked to get it to change the
language to go back to hard copies
should be provided which this language
does not require it provides it as an
option so if we so decide to change the
text of the law to say you know hard
copy you know then that would require
changing the language and changing the
fiscal impact by determining how many
books we'd like to see and how they
would be distributed and frankly I would
suggest that instead of saying this
committee that committee that committee
maybe we can just say hey there are so
many people on education so many people
on the Senate education so many people
are now on finance too and you know add
a few more books and you know say a
total of 50 or whatever be given to the
house and the senator something like
that if we really want to Tinker at this
level but right now the way the law is
written it has no fiscal note because it
does not require a hard copy
I think what we're trying to do is
and the more specific specificity we get
in it the worse off it's going to be
so
if if this is passed just like it is all
it is is taken away even a flag and
saying we think you ought to have some
hard copies
uh
uh and that that again that's a
management decision
so
that's where I am with this I
Mr chair I think it would be appropriate
to make a motion to retain and uh you
know talk to the DOA and see how we can
deal with this because maybe we can take
care of this without needing to pass
along it or maybe a law will be needed
but I would like to you know have a work
session with a doe and just understand
exactly what's the issue okay we have a
motion to retain
okay
okay well right we have four to retain
how many people don't want to retain the
bill
so it's four to two uh four to three
four to three so thank God it would yeah
we'll retain it
now we need to keep track of football
could I have a second
the second was Mary I don't know I'm
saying a second right now if we have
agreement to pass this I would prefer to
pass it as well because it it again it
has been past precedent that
certain number of copies of the
education book have been passed out and
this is
you're right a management issue but
in fact he may require that it be
legislated we've run into this problem
before so I think it's very unfortunate
that we have to pass a bill like this
but it seems that it makes more sense so
I would like to take back my vote and I
would vote with representative Weiler
let's just have a motion to reconsider
yes a motion to reconsider okay and all
this in favor of reconsideration sure
okay now we have a motion to pass along
OTP
all those in favor
okay unanimous I would like to make a
quick note though that what we pass does
not require a hard copy that's right
that's all no he doesn't it says that
there are three
I did
or
it's either of the three
give me the printing
I've done them before in division
oh sorry I tried to get one this time we
did well nobody obviously because
supposing this discretionary fund
you gotta look at me
okay in order of March 521 is our next
bill
do we have anybody this wants to talk to
anybody that can explain it to us
yeah
placement at for an episode of treatment
we're doing 521 yes that's mine
I didn't I'll defer I'll be done you can
I'm Jennifer doll of director of special
education for New Boston in Goffstown
New Hampshire and I've worked throughout
the state in this role as well and I
didn't come with anything prepared I was
just informed today that this was coming
up
so um just real quickly and thinking
about funding that goes towards special
ed it was really interesting listening
to the last you know half hour or so we
get revenues from three sources we get
differentiated Aid that comes through
adequacy it doesn't come to the special
ed Department I don't think there'll be
any gamesmanship about wanting you know
2000 considering the cost of the
educating a child with special education
which is 35 to 45 000 based on the
recent assessment that the state did
it's really just kind of moving chairs
on the Titanic but um this um so we have
um we have the differentiated Aid we
have chapter 402 which is now quarter
replacement revenue and then we have
um the special ed Aid which used to be
catastrophic Aid so this one this new
policy or practice that's been developed
is wonderful it's it's getting services
to children who need it dearly
desperately and they're getting into
placements there's just no
um structure as to who's going to fund
it
um and so in the past any court order
placement there there was a Structure
there was a decision the Ashland
decision years ago which forced
legislation so
So currently I mean our charge in
education and our responsibility to the
town we work in is to appropriately
Place students based on their needs
and if in fact it's required by special
education to fund the educational
portion
um so these students are placed
really outside of the special ed process
and then the districts have to pick up
the full cost of the special ed funding
which is the full day school so if a
child without a disability is placed the
school district doesn't fund anything
but if a child with a disability is
placed it costs us anywhere from 75 to
80 000 annually I've had three in my
district this year some that last
several years so it's it's new it's a
it's a valuable I think practice
um but there's just no structure to it
and we can't anticipate the costs so a
small District like New Boston you know
gets hit with three kids and that just
blows blows things up so I think um you
know uh just considering those those
Revenue sources
um
is very challenging and again those go
to the adequacy level or they go to the
district they don't necessarily go to
special education
and
question what is an episode of treatment
can you describe it not really I mean
this was this is what um if a child's in
crisis it's through DHHS and dcyf if a
child's in crisis
um and the state needs to place them so
they get the services they need they
call it an episode of treatment it was
just a name I think that was given so a
child I think intentionally it was
supposed to be a 60 to 90 day placement
but this turns into you know multiple
years in some situations
um so and it's it's all new it's all
within the last couple of years so an
episode of treatment is just what we
call so what the state does is it's
hired a third party vendor to determine
who which child needs placement that's
Maxim and so this third party vendor
does an assessment and determines
whether a child needs a placement and
then figuring out who's going to fund it
is the biggest challenge
about Medicaid for schools do they ever
cover any of this Medicaid for schools
we've lost millions in the last couple
of years
um that's a whole different story
um no I I don't think we could build
Medicaid for schools we've
um that's changed considered sounds like
a medical condition
well it it in many cases it's a family
situation right so it's a situation
where the family is struggling and with
mental health issues or Finance issues
or something and the child is really you
know needs to be somewhere to get
support and and regulation
um so it's wonderful the States you know
doing this now because there's so many
kids with so much need I think it's just
adding some structure to who's going to
fund it and it was really schools were
not involved in in the decision making
regarding this so it came as a surprise
and has had an impact on out of District
budget
dcyf get involved it is a dcyf DHHS
program so there's a new Bureau called
The Bureau of Behavioral Health I
believe
they pretty much have hired a vendor I
think to do the work
um and uh so if we have a child that we
need that we feel needs or anybody a
doctor a parent needs placement or is in
crisis they have to
um request a cat assessment in this
third party vendor administers the cat
assessment and determines where a child
needs to go if I could just as just to
follow up on representative Euler's
question as a corresponder of the bill
the definition for episode of treatment
is right at the beginning of this it's
adding the you know Roman numeral seven
to the existing definitions and it
basically refers to a situation where
DHHS makes the decision the local school
Authority you know this is a placement
no go ahead DHHS will tell you that it's
a cat it has to go through the cat the
third party vendor so it's not really
it's hard it's hard to untangle but yes
it's a it's a DHHS DS d-wise and because
the state you know creates those
policies and requests them to be
implemented and really the school local
school districts don't have much to say
in this you know then we do have an
obligation to also fund it otherwise it
becomes a 28 day issue where we tell the
schools you have to do exactly this and
by the way you don't even get to make
the decision we tell you and which is
again it's good policy because it is a
useful policy it serves kids in needs
but because the decision is made at the
state level the intent of this bill is
to match the funding you know whether
places where the decisions are being
made and make sure the funding for
specifically for those episodes of
treatments ordered under this policy are
also covered by you know the state who
is making the decisions that's in a
nutshell this bill well it's got a
fiscal note but it doesn't have any
costs
the costs are significant I mean can't
to cheer could I just ask I don't
understand what cat is
so um this agency Maxim has an
assessment
um and it's a you know protected
assessment so we don't really know what
it's all about
so they interview folks involved and
make a decision there's been times when
the school hasn't even been involved so
so no it's it's a different it's a
different assessment that was developed
so can I give an example so um
for example a family has a child who is
out of control they call the police the
police come
they don't know what to do there isn't a
place to send the child
um so is is this what we're talking
about this is an episodic or it could be
a child that's severely severely
depressed and suicidal in which many
situations are about children who are
suicidal and the safety is critical so
they need to they need to be in a
therapeutic setting uh we unfortunately
this doesn't necessarily Place students
in you know therapeutic settings that
have psychiatrists and so forth but I
think that's the plan
so once upon a time
when I used to work in your school
district
um we had kind of like a sort of like a
chance yeah that seems to have gone away
I I don't I can't speak so the quarter
placements have gone down considerably
and that was where children would be
placed
um children in need and you know through
whatever venue or Avenue
um and we would fund that through what I
called the chapter 402 which is anything
above three times the cost we would uh
the state would pick up so this is good
so um
so we really do we have an estimated
number of students that this impacts it
could be it could vary and it could vary
by I would expect that my city of
Manchester has a large number of
students that would relate here yes and
and yes
and currently the school district is
carrying that burden the school district
um
is carrying I I don't know how the
school district is dealing with it
um it like I said there's no structure
to this so we'll sit down at the table
and say this kid is in such trouble but
we're we're allocating local funds to a
situation that may not be you know I
mean that is bigger and may not even be
educationally related so I would imagine
the biggest cities in the state and
Rochester and Claremont are having this
is happening in in you know areas where
there's some struggle economically and
is your average District I would say and
and we've got three students currently
and one that just came back up one that
just came back and two others so
so how do we come up with the dollar
figure for this because it's really
we are living in a Time
kids have been impacted by covid
um there are a lot of apparently mental
health issues that have increased
significantly
um at public hearings I heard
unbelievable testimony from families in
crisis over this situation
um how do we how do we can I handle
around what it what's its shape
so I think this is this is one is on
it's very difficult to unpack given that
there's a third party vendor and it's
hard to get information about what's
going on with that but I can tell you
with all seriousness I've got students
in crisis and parents will send me
letters saying I can't get an
appointment until September or October
and they're suicidal right now so I it's
a really huge issue
um and I think you know
there's Mo I'm pleased that the state is
has put together a way for families in
crisis to um to get some help it's just
there's a long list of kids for this and
um it's having an impact on
funding
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh yeah I uh I was on
a school board in Farmington we had
something like uh 22 to 25 out of
districts
and at a cost of uh over a million
dollars about ninety five thousand
dollars per student
and it was it was quite a burden I mean
when you figure there's only 900
students so we got a 14 million dollar
budget so that was special Aid cost was
4.6 million dollars
I mean it takes away from your
mainstream kits and that's and that's
you know the Indian some of you don't
have any choice with court ordered which
I believe a 402's exactly yeah it used
to be called 402 now we call it court
ordered yeah oh oh just court ordered it
it was called that chapter 402. um and
the extraordinary that's costs are
extraordinary if you look at the big
cities even the moderate districts the
auto District costs are very very high
do we do we have any idea what the
popular you know what population that
affects in other words like special ed
is around thirty thousand
so special is um
said it's been increasing at the state
level um the number of kids hasn't
changed when you count the number of
kids with special education it's
including all kids in charter schools
it's including kids in private schools
because leas have to have responsibility
for all of these kids so the number
comparably to students without
disabilities is changing because those
kids are moving into other areas right
but we're still responsible for kids
whether they go somewhere else or not
that's why the number
pair it appears as though while the
general population is shrinking
um the kids with disabilities are
increasing but what's happening is the
general proper population is moving into
other avenues for education but the
local Lea is still responsible
financially for students
um which is very in charter schools for
example we have no control over what
occurs how you know but we're fully
responsible and if somebody were to take
us to court it would be the District of
liability that would have to go to court
and defend fape
right now as a charter school have you
are you ever contracted by the Lea to to
provide services so I I work for I'm at
the SAU in a public District so okay so
when we have contracts with Charter
Schools they hire people
um or we find people from contract
agencies to send in
um so we're responsible for funding
whatever occurs in that IEP
um
again is that your question well well
it's it's in other words well I I know I
was going over to manifest and uh one of
our students from Farmington was at uh
uh a Catholic School in Rochester and I
noticed on a man on the manifesto hey
what's what's this doing there and they
were providing Services yeah so I mean
it's it's it does happen and uh it's
quite significant oh yeah there's a
large population of students that are
and and our our student population is
around 22 to 24 percent
of in special ed which is that's
pretty significant and I think it's it's
um in many districts gotten up that high
so right now are we seeing any measure
of uh increase in academic achievement
through this or I mean you know it's
it seems so we never I and that and
that's a question I'm on the budget
committee also there and you always ask
the question well how many kids come off
a special ed and you never seem to see
many come off especially well I can tell
you it's very challenging to get a valid
uh estimate of achievement meaning that
the state assessments that we use are
not Norm referenced or standardized
there it's a bar you jump over right so
the best predictor of the state predicts
the socioeconomic the state assessment
is very good at predicting this
socioeconomic status of a community
other than that it's a little
wishy-washy right so I mean comparing
Bedford to um
comparing Bedford to Berlin
um
we know that uh you know the what occurs
in the home plays a big role in
education and what resources are
available so uh the best predictor of
socioeconomic status is our state
assessments it's not it's not a
predictor of student achievement meaning
if you've got a child that's deaf or
blind or uh very cognitively impaired or
so that test is just not going to give
you any any measurement of of you know
true achievement
right well if if I'm honorable thanks uh
no I believe I've seen a a uh a scatter
diagram of uh free reduced this was in
both schools I believe and was brought
up at a National Conference actually
which was kind of neat and it showed
that even if you were poor
the it did you know you still could
achieve at a very high level so
I'll be honest with you I did my
dissertation on education funding in New
Hampshire and the
funding uh is associated with three
factors poverty urbanicity which is both
um you know sitting uh and spending so
um achievement I'm sorry is is very
connected to or you can predict
achievement based on socioeconomic
status
um urbanicity because there's different
complexities in an urban setting
um and uh per pupil spending those are
the three factors in in my estimate
contribute the most to student
achievement so I I also study that
Kuwait uh intentionally and there's a
Lexington Institute study of uh Abbott
districts in New Jersey and they spend
forty four thousand dollars per student
and their academic achievement is
actually going down and that's that's
unbelievable that that is unbelievable
um thank you uh thank you can I ask a
few either or or yes no questions
because I'm having a hard time
understanding this whole thing frankly
Okay so
thank you first thanks for that
um are these court ordered
children
who need an episode of treatment or
these two separate things court ordered
and is episode treatment so they're
separate so they're these are not court
ordered children these are not involved
with court ordered placements okay just
let me
one at a time okay so these are children
who have somewhere there's been an
episode of treatment you gave the
example of a student who's severely
depressed and the parents like you know
help me I don't know what to do
um
how is that addressed how is that being
I guess uh let me think how is that
being addressed now
and why would DHHS
get involved If the parents are saying
my kid is depressed as opposed to why is
DHHS involved in this who are these kids
where DHHS gets involved my
understanding what I thought I
understood at first is that somehow
these are children that are housed with
it not housed physically but
um
educationally dhss has responsibility
over these children do they have
responsibility over these children no I
think the state calls it a parent choice
so the parent has chosen to access have
DHHS intervene with this with this child
correct and DHHS says again get out DHHS
I know um
um says we're going to do this cat thing
and figure out what you need and then
DHHS based on this cat thing
says you're going to go to this school
and get this treatment and the problem
that you're seeing is that no one is
paying for that treatment or the school
is getting stuck with that payment so
the to that am I kind of on the right
track here yes okay can I I'll give you
an example A Child's Very um
the problem with suicidality is there's
no placements for kids really so many
are going out of state or somewhere else
but if a child is in crisis behaviorally
very young often the kids will be
pleasant Mount Prospect Academy up north
and it's costly so the state will pick
up the cost of the residents and then
the educational portion would then
become the responsibility of the school
district
so is are this so you're talking about
this child who was removed from the
family and moved to this residential are
all these children moved to a
residential place I guess part of that
question is if a child is divorced or
depressed
what can the school do um there's not a
one-off here in terms of an episode of
treatment that treatment of depression
is a long-term kind of a treatment so do
the all these kids go to a residential
Place through DHHS so um prior to being
placed there's fast forward so there's
some uh so this these are kids that the
schools you know we would argue and
probably not in all cases but that the
schools are able to manage these kids
it's easier almost at school when you're
dealing with kids we've got therapists
psychologists and so forth but it's when
they leave school that is problematic
and that's what parents would go to you
know this Agency for and say I we need
help
does that make sense
yeah but when you talk about school can
you use an adjective of the public
school they're going to or the
residential school when you say when
they leave the school which school is at
the public school and they go home and
that's the problem or when they leave
the residential schools the problem
before they're placed right they're in
public school and they're having trouble
at home
parents go to the agency and ask for
help and it could it could start with
fast forward
and some other things that occur but
um then a child is placed residentially
far away you know in many cases so then
they're in school wherever they're
placed so the cost of that schooling
then goes to the Lea
so Doug is one other thing thank you so
much for your forbearance here
um
episode of treatment
could be and I'm going to exaggerate it
could be that they go to this
residential school for the next five
years it could be they sit down at the
public school with a counselor
um how many what what is an episode of
treatment unit
you would think that it's not a unit
it's just so what happens in the school
is separate from this right
so the kids this is
so what's happened if a child's in the
public schools and they're in crisis
right and we have counselors and they're
so we're doing that already
so then
um fast forward is an agency I think
that's part of this cat assessment
behavioral organ uh Bureau that would go
in and try to provide therapy or
guidance to the family if that doesn't
work they'll then do the cat assessment
and be placed somewhere else sometimes
do they go directly to the cat
assessment and get so the challenge is
just with the lack of structure as to
who's funding this
but my question will is
at what point is it a health issue and
not an education issue
that's the question
um and it health meaning mental health
meaning behavioral health physical
health all of the above and in in many
times it's not an educational issue but
there's no
there's no you know way to fund it I
think maybe on some occasions the state
picks up the full cost but I'm
I would imagine if so if a child doesn't
have an IEP there's no cost to the Lea
it's just for students with IEPs
okay Mary I am very troubled by the fact
that the school district the Lea is not
involved at all which
I don't I I just I don't understand how
that can happen
um I understand
um definitions you have children that
who are on an IEP and you have children
non-ie-p and the payment process is
and for those children who are are
served by an IEP
who have been put in the situation
by helping Human Services there's no
coordination with the school district
but the school district has to pay
yeah
I appreciate it um basically
as the discussion shows this is a
complicated topic right there are kids
in trouble there are a lot of agencies
that get involved I actually appreciate
a lot of the questions from the
committee because they helped you know
provide more background on exactly how
this works but at the end of the day
what this law is trying to address is
that when all this process works through
and the conclusion is Rich that you know
in the best of interest of the child
that child has to be placed through this
program and you've heard the safeguards
and the steps involved and whatnot
there is there are certain costs for the
you know education of the child that you
know are not no longer covered under
that program and they fall to the local
school district and this is this law is
trying to make clear that you know in
that case the state should pick up that
particular burden because this is a
program that's really controlled by the
state and designed to serve the best
interests of the child but exactly as
representative has what Heath was saying
the school district cannot really
control the outcome of this it's not
really appropriate to you know have them
pay that
tuition associated with it that they
don't you know have a control I mean
it's hard enough the way we have the
special education laws that really limit
the ability of the school districts to
worry about because but this one is
further out than that because they don't
really control that process so it's an
attempt to match again the decision
making and the you know with the funding
your bill but you have been fabulous I
have to say and it's so wonderful to see
you after all these years
um
this
just the whole process
flies in the face of idea
I'm
is this New Hampshire specific
I I so New Hampshire is very unique
in so many different ways if a child is
placed by the courts the only the only
children in the schools need to fund the
education portion for our children with
disabilities so if a child without a
disability is placed in
um
uh let's say our I'm trying to think of
a residential facility uh in a
residential facility if they have an IEP
the Lea is responsible for funding and
if they don't the state funds it
and we go ahead we just have no fiscal
note we have absolutely no idea of what
we're
um
saying that we need to budget for Once
Upon a Time with court order placements
I remember when I was at the department
the line was empty because we just knew
we had to pay it right
that's what I feel like we're going to
be doing here is it going to be a line
and we have a question mark in it and
how do we put a number in it that that
is what I'm worried about plus the
process all around
and I want to say it's desperately
needed um I agree my preference would be
it wasn't a third party that has some
formula for this but
um it's desperately needed and I just it
there needs to be some you know
structure to it I think so this would
provide respite for the school districts
this bill
is respite for the school districts oh
no what do you what do you mean I mean
in terms of money
came in oh yeah yeah we would be yes yes
correct all right thank you
Mr chair if I may
excuse me thank you I am equally
concerned by the fact that we don't have
an estimate and on one hand I can
understand why because of the
complexities of this it was hard to get
an estimate you know at the time when
the bill was designed and whatnot but I
completely agree that we do need to work
with the doe and see for in the HHS and
everybody involved in just try to at
least get a forecast based on the
current practices there should be some
data somewhere that maybe wasn't yet
made available but we do need to hear
because we will need to basically set
aside of a reserve for this we may not
be able to know the exact dollars but we
do need to have an understanding of the
ballpark and decide whether we will fund
it you know the way it is or will cap it
and figure it you know there has to be a
way to estimate that before we
finalize the budget I mean obviously you
cannot write a blank check and this is
not the intent of this
who just as more of a point of Interest
Who makes the decision
that the student's going to go to a
residence is that a DHHS decision or is
it my understanding is it's the third
party vendor
huh
and the parent chooses whether or not
it's a parent choice okay just just to
clarify while the decision may be made
by the vendor the vendor is acting on
behalf of the state government so you
know whether it's the agency directory
or a subcontract that they retain for
the program at the end of the day the
control is with the state agency that
runs the program they may not make the
day by day decisions but they do control
the policy and the implementation we're
that it's a you know
and there really is is running the show
on this so
um but and but they're paid by DHHS
correct so it's a third party vendor and
whether or not DHHS you know has the
final say I would say they probably do
have some influence and step in
thank you Mr chair would it be useful to
hear from DHS on this or from division
three
in terms I mean this is complicated this
goes across so many different areas I'm
still struggling spending money on this
right now
I'm assuming uh through this third party
vendor yeah we're paying about 75 000
per child
in the district right correct
so
but the the vendor and I I think I think
perhaps maybe parents who are Medicaid
eligible I don't know I don't know how
it's funded through
the state well that was the next
question if this is a health issue then
either Medicaid or a family health plan
or something sense to me like should be
the funding source or not the state uh
or am I all wet here
I mean I've been at this a long time
um there was a time when we had a
facility with seven psychiatrists right
there's there's nothing anymore so it's
very very hard
um
so to find solutions for the kids and
and to figure out you know how to manage
all of the complexities of all of this
um I think the intentions were very good
on on everybody's part
um
okay so you have any ideas of how we
might go about finding out
skinny data so we did get late very late
in the game from the Department of
Education some essentially an
indeterminable type fiscal note because
it is hard to predict this they did
report that HHS in 2122 school year had
50 students or 50 young folks that would
apply that this would have applied for
as far as what the costs are and any
state
funds that were distributed on behalf of
those students I don't know we didn't
get any information from DHHS on this
bill
and I was hoping we'd have perhaps some
agency folks here today and we don't so
I don't know if you want to
recess this work session or if you uh
you know treat it like your other bills
and retain it and have it be part of a
host Bill one house bill two court
ordered placements of course is in the
budget there's four and a half million
dollars carried as a budget line item
there also is an open warrant like there
has been for years for that program so
whatever the liability is for the state
it is it is covered the department of Ed
can go to the Comptroller and get funds
and this would just include those
episode of treatments in that line item
so the state would would pay whatever it
is I just don't know if anyone has an
estimate for the next two years well
somebody's going to be approving
invoices from the vendor I mean there's
there's got to be somebody somewhere
that knows something
so yeah well my question then Mickey is
can we say that that students in this
category would fall into court ordered
placements and the payment would be
come out of that line
and we'd have to increase it accordingly
I'm not sure how many students or
you may have
some of the there may be some overlap I
think I don't I don't really know the
specifics of this but whatever that line
item is for quarter Replacements is that
what you're asking like well this it has
comparable attributes except the court
ordered is court ordered and this is
apparently HHS accorded right um and
quite frankly this bill was
overwhelmingly supported by many and as
as a parent and as a administrator I
would love this bill
um because it does a lot of things I
just am trying to figure out where to
put it how to fund it
um and get the help that people need
because it sounds like we really need to
do this and it's a I think greatly a
mental health issue oh it is it is yeah
so my suggestion would be to you know
pretty much continue the current
practice I mean the intent of this bill
is to essentially just add placement for
an episode of treatment to the statute
that already handles the out you know
the court ordered stuff so they would be
falling under the same rules same
everything but we do definitely need to
consider the financial impact because we
cannot just
squeeze everybody in and keep that
budget line the same we do have to get
those numbers from wherever they are and
figure out what the forecast is because
we should Reserve those funds open
warrants are all nice and good but it is
not okay to just say well we'll worry
about the cost when we get there we we
do need to make a best effort get as
good information as we can on what is
the expected cost understanding that you
know there is
it's hard to forecast correctly but we
do need to adjust that line item
accordingly
an option would be to recess the work
session and I can try to follow up with
you know the department of Ed and the
Department of Health and Human Services
to see you do that to see if anyone can
give us a ballpark estimate I know it's
probably a difficult one to predict and
then at least you'll have some
information to proceed but uh but my
point is I don't know if it's going to
be that hard because we're doing it
we're already doing this
I think we're in year three in a
different form
uh and all this is doing is they do this
you're keep doing what you're doing so
somebody's paying that that's up that
subcontractor
and and the state somebody has to pay
the other portion
we're paying for the School portion for
okay
trying to research where it says an
episode is defined in RSA 193 colon 27
it is
it's inserted
oh I looked it up too because I forgot
it was defined here it's an addition to
the definition so it's the definition is
well let's recess and see if we can give
them a little more information but to me
all this all this is caught doing is
codifying what we're already doing
it's just changing the funding yes yeah
well it's in the statute
okay thank you thank you very much for
your testimony thank you I'm probably
going to go to one o'clock for the 5 27
over in threes but I'll be back after
that okay so let's take lunch until one
from the Department of Health and Human
Services here who I think could maybe
shed a little bit of late and answer
some questions on House Bill 521 where
mine don't either well I'll get a hand
wrist slap good afternoon Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is Rebecca Ross I'm the director
of The Bureau for children's Behavioral
Health at the Department of Health and
Human Services and I am happy to help
answer any questions or provide
explanation well we have a we have a
bill before us that expands uh
existing law
and talks about episodes
and we had some testimony this morning
that said
students that are subject to this
uh
I'm trying to figure out what the right
words are we don't know who pays for it
okay and we don't know how many there
are we're not objecting to paying for it
but we're going to get our arms around
how many students are and I can't
remember the company cat was it yeah cat
was the evaluator
I am happy to give you the background on
the transformation of residential
treatment in New Hampshire I will try to
give it at the highest level but can
provide more detail if that'll be
helpful so consistent with RSA 135 F and
the system of care for children's
Behavioral Health
we shifted Residential Treatment from a
dcyf or division for children youth and
families child protection and Juvenile
Justice only service to a department
service so that any child who is in need
of behavioral health treatment at a
residential level can access that
treatment without having to be court
involved so this is to serve kids when
they need it where they need it without
a punitive Court involvement until or
unless that's necessary prior to that
there was no access so that's that's the
shift previously under 126 I believe
it's 126 U
um the there was an exception or a
change in the way
education was paid for children in
residential with IEPs if they were dcyf
or court involved but because we're
removing that step the law left a gap
for payment for kids who are going
directly to that same type of
residential service for the same type of
Behavioral Health need
but their families not court involved so
this is an attempt to close that Gap if
I may uh Mr chairman uh when when did
that change take effect
approximately two
you know we started serving kids
directly when we really received this
funding from SB 14 which was the the
biggest modification to that system of
care it was originally established in
2016 but the residential component came
in with that budget and then essentially
rolled out at the beginning of the
current biennium and a student do they
have to have an IEP to qualify
no so there are about 25 of the youth
that we are serving directly in
residential do not have IEPs now they
may be in the process of being evaluated
for one ultimately they may have one but
currently upon admission or upon
requests for admission they don't have
them so we're talking about 75 percent
of the non-dcyf youth
Mary so let me see if I have this
straight so we have two populations of
children
being served by this process
so we have children who are not they do
not have an IEP
and for those children they are placed
after they go through this evaluation
and the state pays for them
and are placed
those children their services are
charged to the Lea
no
only if they are dcyf involved So
currently well that's what I meant for
those children going the same process
but two different populations so that
children who are not iepied
children who do not have an individual
education plan
the state pays for them
through defense once they go through the
evaluation they're part of the
behavioral
um so I think there's there's two
different layers or two different
categories first there's are they
involved with dcyf or division for
children youth and families yes or no if
the answer is no then the behavioral
health system steps in and then the
behavioral health system has to decide
do they have an IEP yes or no currently
unless the school changes the IEP to
include that residential treatment
Bureau of children's Behavioral Health
is paying for the education for both
kids with IEPs and without IEPs this
bill would address the population with
IEPs we will still be paying for
education for those without IEPs
okay
so
what I think we're considering
and I'm speaking for I think
we have district court ordered
placements yes so we would add an
element
for this population of children to that
line
yes and this would be additional funds
that would go to the school district I
understand
for children who have IEPs and are
placed by you
so I am not the expert on the
Educational Funding piece except to say
right now I'm paying for the majority of
it out of DHHS funding but this is where
there's there's a cap so as soon as they
exceed a certain amount it kicks to doe
as far as the Appropriations or any
change
I'm not the person to answer that
question
if I may go ahead yeah thank you uh Mr
chair
um how many kids involved in each
category do if you know
sure so today there are less than
350 youth total in residential placement
through DHHS there are other youth who
are in educational placements through
school and we're not talking about those
so exclusively through DHHS there are
less than 350 of those between 60 to 70
are not involved with dcyf the remainder
are the expectation is that over the
coming years more and more will shift to
the voluntary system because it's
available and can be accessed earlier
than the Intensive court process so
while we don't expect to see an increase
in the overall number in residential
more will be served directly through the
voluntary system and less will be
through the dcyf system yeah
I just wanted to um clarify that on page
three line is two to five
that clearly defines what will be paid
for it specifically says any course of
special education or special education
and related Services related to an
episode of treatment and the termination
of placement by the DHHS shall be
covered in full for students with
disabilities by Doe that's that's
exactly the population that is being
addressed by this bill the rest of the
bill just adds the necessary language to
make sure that those services are
I just want to say thank you this
for years we've heard testimony about
children in crisis we've heard from
parents who have been beside themselves
they don't know what to do
so from what I'm understanding parents
can come to you in crisis and you will
help them
yes and we've opened up a number of
Pathways including rapid response and
the mobile teams that have changed how
they get to us but absolutely that's
exactly what we've done and the cat
assessment that you heard about before
is the comprehensive assessment for
treatment
which determines what level of
Residential Treatment they need and if
they are clinically eligible for
residential treatment so we've
contracted with Maximus a National
Vendor who does an assessment using the
Child and Adolescent needs and strengths
tool as well as interviews and document
review to determine
um whether or not they're clinically
eligible and at what level our treatment
providers are now levels one through
five including five which is the
psychiatric residential treatment
facility that we're looking to open up
at Hampstead Hospital and so we have
changed to a Contracting model with all
of our Residential Treatment providers
and for the first time we're starting to
have data on the clinical needs the
strengths
and the levels of care that over time
will be able to dial in much better how
much and what type of residential
treatment we need to minimize it and
just to follow up on that so when the
child leaves residential placement is
there a transition plan for them yes so
that's part of our through our intensive
community-based programming in our Care
Management entities also part of the
system of care the transitional
residential enhanced care coordination
is available to everyone in residential
through bcbh and that's where a care
coordinator is working with the child
and the family to put the pieces in
place so that upon discharge all of
those services and supports are in place
when they return back to the school and
Community finally just one related to
the those individuals with EPS yes um
you so there is a connection to the
school district for that child to have
that added to their plan
so the school districts are responsible
for their IEPs and we don't
try to impose this what we try to do is
have a partnership so that when the
child is in residential we're meeting
their individual family
behavioral and educational needs and
there's a plan in place to return to all
of those as soon as it's clinically
appropriate so we would include them in
all thank you planning
great you haven't asked a question yet
oh you noticed thank you thank you
because this is finally making some
sense so just a couple things to clarify
um I missed the the students that we're
talking about they do have IEPs or they
don't have IEPs for the purpose of this
bill these are the students with IEPs
the ones that do okay I thought that's
what I really want to make for now we
continue we will continue to pay the
educational costs for the placements for
other youth who are and without the IEPs
um so a mobile crisis unit I could say
is it is it accurate to say that that's
a tool in your kit yes and so this is
going back to kids who are stuck in the
hospital for a psychiatric reason and
they're there for three months because
there's no place so this is addressing
that problem okay and right now I think
what we're trying to figure out before
DHHS is paying this and this would come
to the education
is there are we moving money from DHS
who you're paying for it now yes so is
this a change of where the money is
going to come from that it's not coming
from you anymore it would come from one
of our division two or is it because if
you're not going to be paying for it
anymore
we will where is it coming out of here
and
why so they're going to continue to pay
for it
so where is it coming out of our part of
the budget why isn't it in division
three I that's the question I asked her
this morning uh why isn't this in the
DHHS why isn't it why are we in division
two I yeah if I may I cannot speak for
leadership and who sends bills to what
committee but this is a special
education bill so while the control you
know for the placement is through DHHS
and you could argue you could go to
division three this affects education
funding in schools because it
specifically talks about the fact that
the the the Department of Education will
now be responsible so I'm guessing
that's why it's yeah but the question is
where's the line item for the money
right now there's money that's paying
for it from DHHS well presumably but
it's it's worth the line to know who's
in charge of paying for it it's their
if I may
um
when we were allocated funds to pay for
residential treatment it was not
anticipated that this would create such
confusion on the IEPs we were not
budgeted to pay for Education expenses
our we were paying for it out of
Residential Treatment dollars in order
to ensure that children are being
educated which means we can't serve as
many children
um therapeutically because we're
covering the cost of special education
so there is no line item for education
in my budget but it's being covered at
the detriment of what we're statutorily
charged with covering but getting to the
essence of that comment
how much is it how much is that budget
my residential budget
um I mean I I would have to go back we
it's
for this population I would have to pull
it apart and get back to you because
it's such mixed funding we have
contracts but some of it is dcyf funding
some of it is Medicaid funding and then
there's a mix and so I would have to put
a picture on the spot yeah it's just
complicated you got to build before us
it sounds like it's codifying what we're
already doing
yes but and it's coming out is coming
out of a budget the 350 number
is that
through the year or today
that's a point in time or an average
point in time but the 350 number is
um
includes the whole dcyf population so
we're not anticipating that the the
number that we're looking at for the
next couple years right now if we're at
70 by the end of the month I think it's
realistic to say that we would be
serving around a hundred over the next
biennium at any point in time
um and 75 percent of that will be
special education or kids with IEPs so
if we're looking at we're looking at the
cost of education for approximately 75
to 100 youth per year
and how much is
budgetarily
help me here sure what should we budget
so it's annualized
um and depending on the severity and of
the illness and the needs of the youth
are programs educational rates range
from 150 to 450 a day
um
times 365 because it's annualized so in
that means it's about this big if I had
planned on being here today I could have
done that math at least napkin math a
little bit better but um when we looked
at it we were looking at about two
million dollars a year
finally
a number I don't trust that math that's
my very very rough math but
um but that that's who we're talking
about paying for their educational jobs
could you put pencils and paper and did
it come up if it's two million fine we
need to we need to order a magnitude
budgetarily
yeah and I just want to ask
um
what this bill will do I want to make
sure we are all on the same page is that
it would
stop putting yoga your department on the
hook for education and make sure that
that education is taken care of by the
doe either for relieving your budget so
you can focus out on your core mission
is and the deal we should focus on their
core mission is instead of the current
jumble
um implementation of this transformation
is an iterative process and I think
we've learned a lot in the first couple
years we'll continue to learn but
absolutely now we're now all we got to
do is convince doe they got a new egg in
their basket
well they give them money they'll be
happy yeah that's what I'm saying I mean
we're going to budget somebody to do
this so so
I just want to go back to court ordered
placements that line in the budget
so does it make sense to add
the popular specified population as
maybe another like
a underneath that line for this
population at two million dollars I'm
hearing because now quarter Replacements
that's kind of like an open warrant sort
of thing because it can go over and I I
am feeling like this would need that
same kind of thing does that make sense
what I'm trying to say
yes but I I am also who's budgets it in
because right now you always
yeah okay there's four and a half
million per year included in the
governor's recommended budget for court
ordered placements and there is a
statutory open warrant so if that actual
cost has to be six million dollars doe
can draw a warrant for the additional
amount they need outside of the budget
process to pay that liability
this would include the episode of
treatments in that line item right so
along the lines if if two million
dollars ends up being the number that
this committee is comfortable with we
would increase
this 400 and a half to six and a half to
reflect the cost of this bill but that
open warrant would still be there if
your estimate is wrong
well we would have to amend this bill uh
not necessarily so with this being a
direct budget impact bill this would be
one you'd consider retaining and we
would put this in House Bill too also as
part of House Bill 2 there is a change
court ordered placements has
historically been a general fund charge
this budget changes that to an education
trust fund so there's already a section
in House Bill 2 relative to the source
of funding for so there is a Nexus of
putting this in-house Bill too with that
section with the funding levels as part
of your budget just goes right there too
so you've got a partner yeah got a new
partner called Department of Education
yes which is a good thing we partnered
with them regularly well I'm just saying
this but that is you heard you heard it
here yes so Mickey do we entertain a
motion now to retain yes fold it hold it
with emotions
while you're doing your paperwork and I
say thank you for the explanation this
really helped thank you for identifying
the population which I was a hard time
figuring out and thank you for
differentiating that these are students
who haven't done anything criminal who
should not be in a punitive situation
and this is their Avenue to deal with
that issue without having to go through
the police and you know the issues we've
had with that so thank you for all that
and thank you all for your support of
the system of care we're really already
seeing the benefits of it good amazing
we don't have chairman Weiler and the
motion was by to retain no cool I did it
so so when we do a another budget work
session if you recall the schedule that
I had yesterday carrying the cost of the
bills I'll include this when the
retained bills and I'll work with the
Department of Health and Human Services
and Department of Education and make
sure 2 million a year is what they think
give them a chance to go back and look
and then we could add that if you
support this bill we'd incorporate it
but that's an open open warrant it is
still an open warrant but at least
there's a some reflection of you guys
are recognizing that it's going to cost
a little bit more than under current law
because you're making this change yeah I
had to change the uh
definition of that line
well if it's all under court order yeah
I mean the title of that accounting unit
is court ordered placements uh so we
could do a little bit of finagling so
there's it's transparent that it's court
ordered placements and episode of
treatment you know or whatever we could
come up with something okay so we have a
who who seconded it
um Kate I have the second I'm good all
in favor of retaining
unanimous wow that's another one down to
okay
yeah
sure sure oh my God
which one you want to do first I'll do 6
21st this should be really quick
for the record my name is Mary Heath and
I represent
um District 41 in Manchester and that's
words two four five and seven
um 6 20
um but basically what it does it
establishes
um a department or division of early
learning and in the Department of
Education and it gives authority to the
department to establish a three-year
pilot program what I'm asking today is
that in in hb2 the governor has a new
team people it's efficiency that they're
going to be looking at a lot of things
and right now isn't the right time to do
HB 620 I'm asking you just to retain it
um and then we can take action on it
later but I am not asking to have it
included in the budget at this time so
if you'll indulge me and think about
by
Joe Petri oh second give me a second
Mario
I don't hold motions
they're good
okay and it's always in favor of
retaining
unanimous
all right for that well you know who I
am already
um what I do would like to ask your
Indulgence again I would like to ask an
expert to come and join me
please
um to talk about
hb601 which is Medicaid direct
certification and I think we are going
in a good direction but well while we're
here any questions please introduce
yourself
hi my name is Laura Milliken I'm the
executive director of New Hampshire
my name is Laura Milliken I'm the
executive director of hunger New
and I know we had some questions
yesterday I don't I didn't know if you
had any extra questions
my intent would be to ask that we ask
Mickey
um to create an amendment that would be
co-sponsored by representative Petrie
and myself with the purpose of
authorizing the Department of Education
and Health and Human Services
to enter to
provide the authority
to those agencies when the
direct certification Medicaid direct
certification RFP becomes available is
so USDA will release an RFP to allow new
states to participate in the Medicaid
direct certification pilot project at 39
states are already members of
and at this point in time this probably
would not be available until 26 2026 so
um so I don't
I don't think any funding is required at
this time Mickey I don't know if you
uh so the Department of Education had
identified some costs and they're in the
room now relative to fiscal 24 and 25
the significant cost where this change
of direct certification could impact
adequacy wouldn't be until fiscal 26 so
there's there's I'd say minimal payments
or minimal expenditures in this biennium
relative to this it'd be the following
biennium so to the amendment then we
would need to add that
dollar figure
yeah and I would just want to be clear
on on the amendment so working off of
the bill as before us can we be I just
want to be clear of what we want to add
so do you have a copy of the bill there
so this bill direct it directs
it directs the department of Ed and
Health and Human Services
to
um
seek participation in the Medicaid
direct certification methodology for
School meals for pre and reduced lunch
so we're
um
just asking for the authority
be given to the Department of Ed and
which I I defer to the department I feel
I think this does that already I'm not
sure we would have to do anything we
just so I think what you would probably
be looking to do is uh you just want to
incorporate this into house bill too
yeah which you can yep representative
Petrie are you agreeable with that
so
are you okay I don't know what is there
an amendment we're just looking at 601
and I will say I'm sorry to I think
representative Ladd had hoped to speak
on this bill so I don't know if you want
to recess this and hear from him or if
you're good I just know he had he had
indicated that uh he would he was going
to come back for 601 I don't think he I
don't think he knew we were going to
jump order so he was going to come back
there is no need to recess we can listen
to him anytime because it's retained so
we can just hear we can recess and I can
get down and get him because he's going
it doesn't make any difference and we
still have to listen and work on it so I
just
come back to the break at two o'clock
and we will be uh open the work session
thank you good afternoon Mr chairman and
good afternoon colleagues of mine on
finance here in division two for the
record I'm representative Maureen Mooney
I'm the prime sponsor in speaking in
support of House Bill 272 an act
relative to increasing chartered Public
School per pupil funding
now just a quick review of how charter
schools are funded in New Hampshire
using this Formula First it's the base
adequacy Aid
plus what is then called an additional
Grant and that's found in RSA 194 hyphen
B colon 11 and so forth my bill House
Bill 272 Deals Only with the additional
grant part of the formula only with that
also I want to add that Charter Schools
do receive money it differentiated AIDS
Aid specifically for free and reduced
lunch English English as a second
Learners and so forth but that's
additional to the two pieces of the
formula I just went over
so House Bill 272 again dealing only
with the additional Grant
piece of the formula as amended
increases the statutory additional Grant
given to public charter schools per
overall with this increase
in the additional Grant total per pupil
for public chartered schools
based on the public charter school
funding formula
with the governors across the board
increase in adequacy Aid
would then give
chartered school pupils nine thousand
dollars per pupil
for the charter school now this is an
increase from what it is now right now
a student who attends a chartered public
chartered school
that chartered School receives between 7
and seventy five hundred dollars per
pupil
my bill
plus the governor's adequacy increase
would then raise that amount to nine
thousand dollars per chartered school
pupil
there are several reasons for this
increase in the additional Grant
including
the additional Grant has not been
funding at nine thousand dollars per
pupil is still lower than traditional
Public Schools where the most recent
figure is an average of about nineteen
thousand dollars per pupil
and another reason for the bill is an
increased funding is needed for the
increased enrollment that public charter
schools have received over the past few
years
also want to make mention that this bill
House Bill 272 passed the entire house
on a Division vote on the 22nd of March
the division vote being
348 to 11.
quite an outstanding bipartisan
statement
on behalf of our public chartered
schools in New Hampshire is to see the
increase that takes place in this bill
so with that
I would ask that you
adopt the bill or incorporate the bill
into House Bill 2 so that we can see a
much needed increase happen for our
public chartered school pupils with that
I'll close my testimony and I do have
others that wish to talk after me thank
you but we could also go forward with
the bill as a standalone
yes
we're 348 to 11.
Mickey
there's a couple reasons why we I don't
think we can do that one this would
carry a price tag so we would have to
have a corresponding budget adjustment
to reflect the increase associated with
this bill and two there is a house bill
2 Section relative to charter school
funding in that it changes the CPI
adjustment to uh that two percent per
year that the governor had proposed so
okay RSA 194 B colon 11 is amended
in-house Bill too so I just worry about
conflicting me so the motion would be to
yeah this law is already in there the
increase of that represent Moody's
proposing is not but that could be done
with an amendment for sure
yeah
all right thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you for being here
um how many kids does this uh affect if
you know
right now there are about 4 900
students enrolled in public charter
and I'll make that motion okay motion
to retain and move it into hb2 by Joe
Petri second by mayor Heath all those in
favor
okay that's unanimous
well thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee I would just
ask in that amendment that was mentioned
would you like to for me to draft that
our guy here I can't thank you enough
this has been a great journey for this
bill and we're all very proud and uh
students are Statewide are very grateful
for sure thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee you know it's an easy
one you won the session took five
minutes
it's straight well house has spoken
yes
what's going on
uh anybody here for 4 30
HB 430 I should say
the education
please
good afternoon I'm representative Sally
fellows
um I hope you will look favorably on to
HB 529
what it does is it distributes about
a little under a hundred million dollars
to primarily the school districts that
need it the most
um this current year that we're in
the school districts are benefiting from
the reduction of the swep
T by 100 million dollars but that is
doesn't apply to next year that was a
one-year deal so the 100 million in 529
is pretty much a replacement
in terms of what the state is
contributing for that it does distribute
questions from the floor yes very thank
you Mr chair so Sally thank you for
taking my question representative
fellows
selling I've known each other for a long
time
um
could you just describe the additional
Aid grants the fiscal capacity disparity
in the the fnr in terms of your bill
um okay I I did not come prepared for
this I don't have the spreadsheet that I
did okay but um I can tell you that the
fiscal capacity disparity has to do with
the property tax base that is available
um to each of the communities these that
receive funding so the ones with the
lowest property tax base receive the
most per pupil and the amount that each
Community receives in some cases that's
zero is on a sliding scale so the ones
with the lowest valuation per student
receive the most per student and
um the so that's how the fiscal capacity
disparity part works and the other half
of the well it's not that's um I don't
have in front of me I think the majority
of the money is distributed under that
formula I think about 80 ml million and
about 17 million is distributed on the
same kind of sliding formula but it has
to do with the percentage of students
that are eligible for free and reduced
lunch
so in the governor's formula
um the governor um gave us a nice boost
in the um base numbers
um How would
what would happen if we were to take the
two
that you've specified in this bill
because the governor does have pretty
reduced lunch but I think this would
maybe would add something to it and then
the fiscal capacity
if we added those two
um
to his formula where would we get where
and I think do you mean in terms of cost
cost to the state in terms of cost to
the state and that's an awful question
to ask you off the top of your head I I
I'm sorry but you know what I bet
um well I know that the the two pieces
from 529 are
um adds up to
97 million dollars
I don't know what the governor's part
does clear clearly
my guess would be that that adds more
all right but I don't uh clearly more I
don't know how much and I think the
Department's here and maybe they could
okay
I make the same observation always about
this
uh poverty payment for students that
this is not for the meals it's for
poverty payment
there should be some programs for these
students to give them extra help
but there never is I've said for years
there should be a grant program based
upon what are you doing for homework
health for these children that are
getting the admr it should be available
to everybody but it specifically should
be set up for those students because
they're not probably getting much
homework I'll help at home
and there should be a program in each
School District
specifically to help them and there
never is I think there's one or two
schools that do but they should all be
let's go back to understand a little
better about you referenced swept which
was a one-time you know last year one
time went off
um and I missed the connection between
so I don't know what was why was sweat
brought up with regards to this when you
gave your introductory remarks well
that's just one of the ways that I look
at it in terms of the the you know from
the budget state budget perspective
that
um what happened it's it's I don't you
can call it last year or this
technically we're in it's the fiscal
year we're in right now by reducing
swept
um that
was a benefit to the school districts of
about a hundred million dollars because
that didn't have to come off their
property tax bills and it also increased
the adequacy aid so just in turn that
just in terms of budget for the state
those are sort of the unequal amount of
contribution
to the school district
I guess what does this connect to this
bill
you know
well it it does it doesn't it doesn't it
just in terms of how it affects the
state
drill yeah well thank you Mr chairman
and uh thanks for taking my question
yeah this just really replaces the 100
million it was taken out and and given
to uh the tax base that that's that's
one my my perspective you know it's it's
they're both ways to
um help out school districts financially
and they're just two different
mechanisms so you know one you know this
year we're helping them out to the
extent of a hundred million dollars
through the sweat reduction and the
proposal in 529 is to help them out to
the tune of about 100 million dollars
with a different formula
follow-up could you could you get that
uh chart that you have uh shown to
different towns at some point I didn't
bring it with me
think the department has some detailed
information we can provide to the
committee on on this we we didn't get a
fiscal note out on this bill because the
data wasn't uh to us in time so we
certainly as this committee proceeds
with education funding will run all
scenarios that the committee wants us to
run including 529 as amended right house
House Education committee has copy and
other people might have copies
I'm sorry I didn't bring it with me they
don't handle the money
can I just add that um representative
fellows actually used to run the numbers
at the department of Ed prior to her
retirement so that she did provide us
with um
um a per town
estimate for each
um and we do have that I don't know if
the committee wants us to make copies of
that or not
well
okay okay
we'll receive that at some point I guess
is this something
in some form that already exists or is
this new I um there's so many acronyms
around here I don't know if
admrs is something that's already in
so the way that works average daily
membership is kind of a FTE full-time
equivalent measure so if a student
starts the school year but drops out or
transfers to another state you know
halfway through then the school district
gets credit for half a student and there
are two adms average daily membership is
the F FTE measure and if it if it's admr
that means average daily membership in
Residence that's a count of of students
by the town that they reside in
and if it's ADM a that's average daily
membership in attendance that's the
school district where they attend the
schools because we have oh maybe
13 something like that school districts
that don't even operate schools because
they're small
and then we have quite a few towns that
operate in elementary school district so
they educate their own elementary
students but they they tuition their
high school students to another
School District because they don't have
a high school
so for adequacy Aid what you're looking
at here all of those measures are based
on where the student lives
and that's where the money goes to where
the student lives because
they're the ones the town are in some
manner are going to pay tuition if they
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the questions
at the time when this bill's bill was
introduced you were not most likely yet
aware of the you know Governor's budget
proposal and whatnot does the you know
significant increase in education
funding in that budget alleviates some
of the need for this bill I'm trying to
basically ask had you known at the
beginning what the budget will have been
would you you know would does this bill
um
um it's a good question I I really don't
know because at the time I was working
on that it was like I didn't know there
would be anything else so we were in the
same Darkness so you know everybody was
there but I'm just asking because
obviously
you know there is some there are
significant increases already there that
this bill would also add and I don't
want to quote unquote double count it or
you know and I want to understand the
intent of your bill because maybe you
know it was in 10 in one way or the
other so I think if I were going to do
if I had known ahead of time I certainly
would not have
just wiped out what I presented because
I think the advantage to that is it
sends money to the towns that need it
the most
by increasing the per pupil spending
you're making the same Contra even
contribution across all school districts
so I think that I probably would have
gone for at least some kind of balance
between the two I appreciate it I'm good
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
Sally Sally could you just talk about
fiscals disparity and what how that's
figured
figured out to disperse
um it's it's an equalized valuation per
student
so
equalized evaluation is the fair market
value of the property that's oh thank
you for your market value of the
property that's in the community
and it's divided by the number of
students that you have that that
admr just a strict count of of students
no weights for anything else
I think just
so there are so many different formulas
and I have seen over the years I've seen
a hundred more than a hundred different
ones so it's equalized valuation per
student and
um so the towns that have the lowest
property tax base get the most the most
money for that so there's a huge
disparity I you know some there are some
towns that have
um
less what what is average is a little
over a million dollars per student
um that those are the figures that we've
been using it doesn't figure in
when we see the results of the property
value increases because of covet it will
actually be higher but there are some
towns that only have like eight hundred
thousand dollars per student and why you
use that measure is your thinking in
terms of what can property taxpayers
afford to pay because at the local level
the only way they get money to support
their schools is through the property
tax well other than state aid and
federal aid that's where they come up
with their money
to do that funding so some some towns
they only have eight hundred thousand if
you look in Rockingham County I don't
know what the number is offhand but it's
an awful lot higher than eight hundred
thousand dollars per student you know
it's probably
you know could maybe it's like a 2
million or something it's got to be a
lot more than that and it's in the um
those that property tax base to students
per student is vastly different from one
town to another all across the state you
know they're you know you could have one
town that that has you know three three
million dollars per student the next one
over may only have nine hundred thousand
and you you then you have Waterville
Valley which is not too far from my
house it's something like 23 million
dollars per student so it's vastly
different
so the so the fiscal capacity disparity
Aid doesn't give any money to Waterville
Valley for sure and um focus is giving
the most amount to those on the lower
property value per student and
Mr chairman you have a
we know a number of students that get
so I think Mark knows if I had to take a
guess I'd guess a hundred and sixty
thousand how close uh that was last
year's that's the latest number we have
that's that's
well in hb2 I'm looking at hb2 the
governor on page 63 and the adequacy
formula goes from
697.77 to
756.43 uh for each pupil in the 80th no
that's English language Learners all
right let's get to the right line here
uh but the governor doesn't have any
despair his is equal across the state
I'm looking for where he adds to the
Texas free and reduced but I don't see
it here
yeah
within your community so he's he's going
up about 600 per student this bill goes
third
so it's not yeah so so this bill 529
it's on a sliding scale so the amount
per student is different from one town
to the next okay and it's also it's also
you know smaller pot of money that's
being spread but they're not doing
anything with the money to help the
student that's my problem the bill um it
wasn't in the original bill but but
House Ed put an amendment on the bill
that requires like an accountability
plan except for the ones that get just a
little bit you know some of them don't
get very if it's if they get like less
than 50 000 they don't have to do a plan
but if it's above 50 000 they have to do
give the um Department a plan on how
if anyone else want to contribute to
this
[Music]
sure
so
um
one choose to make here yeah um thank
you Mr chair and members of the uh the
committee
um uh and thanks for your Indulgence
during our executive session we're being
held hostage by the chair
but um but uh I I
did not hear what representative fellows
um said or what uh what any proceeding
um
um uh possibly Mr manchinello uh my
understanding is I think he did prepare
a fiscal uh report uh now on this that I
think corresponds 100 with what um with
what representative fellas had had
presented
in education and um and I think as um as
members of the committee uh certainly
know this uh uh 529 passed unanimously
is that correct from um recommended OTP
by the education committee past the
floor on on a Voice vote and uh and I
think is a a very strong
um uh serves as a strong pillar of
support for our most uh vulnerable
school districts ones that have the
lowest property valuations ones that
have have the highest
concentrations of of low-income families
uh in the in their schools and uh and in
in my opinion I think it pairs very well
with uh with the governor's
um
uh modifications to the uh to the school
funding formula and in particular does
um provides important uh financial
support like I said to the most
challenged communities you know
including communities like Berlin
Pittsfield Newport Claremont
um and uh and so forth so so communities
that wouldn't necessarily see additional
State funding through the increases in
the base adequacy amount or the
differential Aid factors but would lose
significant funds through the
elimination of stabilization which we I
think all agree is something that we
need to um uh to address but but 529
provides I think those those additional
supports for those uh for those uh
communities
question so thank you for let me ask him
a question David Mr representative
lumino
um
and representative lad to both of you
now we have the governor's proposal
if you had your druthers what would you
add to the governor's proposal in
relation to 529
and so what would the formula with what
you are proposing look like in terms of
the governor's budget
so so I think that's a very good
question I um I like the fact that that
that the governor's proposal provides
increases the um the factors associated
with special educate cost factors
associated with special education and
free and reduced price lunch I think uh
the governor also uh goes further and
recognizes That Base adequacy which is
basically the cost of the basket of
goods that that constitutes an adequate
education so we're talking about
this is where I representative lad and I
sometimes have just interesting
discussions on this but it's a bag of
stuff including 40 desks and a
chalkboard and 1 500th of a principal
and all the things that that that
um uh historically have um have come to
a cost total of about thirty nine
hundred dollars and I think the governor
has has proposed increasing that
substantially which is certainly
justifiable given the what the real cost
of that bag of stuff is but it doesn't
really get you to um to to actually
operating a school district in any any
meaningful way and I think we've we've
our committee has heard testimony from
school districts including uh Berlin
um mayor Grenier from Berlin has has
testified we've heard from districts
including Derry New Hampshire and um and
Newport have testified on that certainly
Manchester has
been and uh and uh and they just you
know can't can't do can't provide an
educational program for um for thirty
nine hundred dollars uh uh but uh but I
think the governor has recognized this
recognize that bag of stuff those inputs
cost more so I think that's a good good
move I think the um where the where the
um
where where I would have some and I want
to be careful about calling it criticism
because I I do support obviously
um improving State funding and public
education but when you increase base
you're increasing it you're increasing
the the state obligation to every school
district whether or not you're the city
of Manchester the city of Berlin or the
town of Newcastle and and uh and I think
this is where where some of the
recommendations uh uh that uh that that
came out of the school funding
commission working with representative
Ladd working with um with attorney
ardenshire uh who's the governor's um
appointment to that representative Heath
representative Miler
um representative cascaden who's now in
the education committee uh
um would would would see that that that
the state gets its biggest bang for its
buck when it directs State funds to
where they're needed most so so where a
school district does not have access to
the resources it needs to uh to offer
educational programming the state comes
in and make sure that you've got access
to the resources you need and um and uh
but but I think I'm also being a pragma
being a pragmatist uh saying that I
think the I think the governor's
proposal is responsible uh given the
fact that we've got two court cases
which which really do need to be weighed
in on by by the state supreme court
before we're going to be able to move
um meaningfully in in that direction
both the Rand case with respect to um uh
how how swept is State uh wide education
property tax is organized and then the
conval case
which I think not not only will get into
the um the what the cost of an adequate
education is but also whether the
interpretation of the Constitution is
the first and last dollar
um uh approach or or can the state and
I'm using a term that I think had been
is probably goes back 20 years but it
used to be called targeting
um State money and honestly it was a
partisan issue back then I think
Republicans supported targeting and
Democrats um uh went the other way but
as a Democrat I'm again working with
representative Vlad representative Miler
attorney Arden feel that that this
approach of of targeting directing State
money to where it's needed
um is uh is is not only responsible but
it's uh not only responsible in terms of
education but it's basically responsible
too because it can be done with existing
Revenue sources without substantial
changes to existing Revenue sources and
uh and provide
um strong opportunities for students
across the street State and taxpayer
fairness
um across the state as as well so but
but but practically speaking starting
with the governor's proposal uh I would
I would offer and represent lad
um probably speak to this that that that
I think we could it could be
strengthened with with representative
Ladd some uh proposal through House Bill
540 440 540 540 on um on three
categories of uh of special education
Aid I think you heard that this morning
that would be that would be a a a new
Improvement uh to it and then and then
have have 529 uh parallel you know right
on top of uh the governor's uh plan
providing that fiscal capacity disparity
relief so David what you're saying is
that we would take the percentage of
Freedom reduce
and fiscal capacity disparity and add
those elements to the existing Governor
the existing formula put forth by the
governor and
um that would then give us more Equity
across the state in terms of those
school districts like mine Manchester
and Claremont and others they would be
able to I don't want to say be winners
in this but they would gain the dollars
that could equalize learning
opportunities for all students across
our state yeah I think that's well put I
think adding 529 makes everybody a
winner in this because right now without
529 Manchester gets the same as they did
under do under current where Berlin gets
the same as they do under current law
basically any place that has
stabilization that would lose it
um the governor's hold harmless comes in
to hold them to fy24 current law 529
goes goat would take them beyond that
and provide them with with the the
relief
um uh that they've that they've asked
for that could be done in terms of I
mean it could be used to um to to help
provide a school budget that that meets
the needs of the students and families
but it could also provide the tax relief
that that so many communities need as
well
so this is additive then add 529 would
be in addition to the governor's
proposal and and in addition to
representative Ladd's uh house bill 540.
representative
yeah thank you very much for the record
Rick Ladd from Haverhill New Hampshire
I'm one of those communities which is
um not doing well in terms of Education
funding
I have uh served on both the task force
of the gov the commission which we had a
year and a half ago I was one that was
not supported the recommendations as a
whole but I also recognize the need for
assisting these districts uh the reason
why I wasn't supportive of initially
because was the way we looked at base
adequacy I look at those things those
inputs as absolutely necessary to Define
what our base adequacy is rather than
just taking some number out of the doe
25 form
and saying well that's the average cost
of a student and yes it is maybe but
it's also including things like
Athletics and everything else and I want
to only conclude those things required
for the opportunity for an adequate
education an academic education so I
guess where I'm coming from and I do
appreciate what the governor's doing as
does represent luno here
um
it's important to look at this whole
formula going from left to right
and when you're looking at the left hand
side of the center base adequacy right
now
when you put money in there
you're putting money into the base
adequacy which in some cases some
districts are doing quite well right now
whereas you look further to the right
and you get past you know the
differentiated Aid
and you see those towns which really
need all that money to help even come up
to the level of adequacy that to the
level of money that comes in this site
from the swept and they're not there so
we have to have things such as relief
grants extraordinary needs grants and
I'm looking back at what we recommended
in 2018 under the umberger study and we
saw that there was necessary there is a
need to address these towns where there
is a definite relationship between
performance academic performance and
what they were receiving from the state
in terms of support and funding
and so we got to boost these communities
up and I look back at what we had back
in 2008 nine when Senator Estabrook had
that study and fiscal capacity disparity
Aid was a key factor to that in fact at
that time our hold harmless was only 27
million dollars but now we're looking at
something that's roughly 156 157 million
dollars that means this formula is
broken
and we're funding students as
represented a while or oftentimes say
and maybe the ghost kid because we're a
demographic is shrinking significantly
but with that there's still costs
that these smaller districts have to pay
for they're going to have to pay for
everything from K through 12 and
programs that we as a state have
required them to have
and they are it's much more costly if
you look even at the community college
system to run a course up at White
Mountain Community College opposed to
what they they have here at nhti where
they have the student population per
pupil wise it's more expensive at White
Mountain Community College the same
thing in these rural districts
and so with that in order to provide the
opportunity for AP courses or those
courses which are necessary
for our students to receive that level
of Education we're going to have to put
fiscal capacity as Spirit Aid in there I
don't know if I'd put quite as much into
the base adequacy as slide some of that
into where it better supports the state
as a whole
um
so in conclusion I think that what the
finance committee has to look at how
many of these areas we're going to have
relief grants extraordinary grants
fiscal capacity it's time to consolidate
some of that and build it around medium
family incline Equis property evaluation
per pupil and the physical capacity
needs of those communities as was
established back in Senator estabrook's
day
going from ogenbluck to that formula to
where we are now is we've had change
quite often and quite often it's been
unfortunate discussions between donor
and non-donor
and discussions where the students that
are in these smaller districts are never
the winners as I drove by I think I
mentioned this morning how Piermont is
looking at a 22 percent budget increase
this last year due to special education
needs but not just special education
needs inflationary needs and costs doing
business same thing in Warren another
town which I have a Haverhill same deal
we're like the you know the Charlestown
we're like the Berlin we're like you
know all those can be Franklin's of the
world Newports where it's very difficult
to offer what you in our district as
what supposed drinks next door within a
budding Community which has the ability
to provide those services so I would
look at fiscal capacity just buried Aid
in some form or fashion to send the
money where it's going to do the
greatest good and right now pumping a
huge amount into the right left hand
side of that column may not be what my
first choice is my first choice would be
slide that my money over to the right
side somehow I realized that the base
adequacy and Claremont and Londonderry
we have to provide the same type of
opportunity for wealthy communities as
poor communities I get it
but in order to do that and it's been
the same every year I've been here we
have to be looking at what's on the
right hand side of that column and uh I
I think we have an opportunity to do it
this year and uh
well there's a lot more to this equation
and what we're and that's not on this
particular bill right here so I'll leave
it at that I think I'm echoing some of
what representative luno has said
um I I guess I'm echoing a little bit
more to put more on the right hand side
than the left hand side
thank you
questions
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
for finding the time to come over I know
it is a busy day
I'm just trying to you know I hear what
you're saying about you know you want to
move more money from the left-hand side
where it goes more or less evenly to the
right hand side what is distributed
you know according to the needs of the
community
at which point
do we call it balanced because the way I
look at it you know communities
that have you know higher tax base also
tend to have higher costs in every other
way I mean building a building in uh you
know
building a school in Windham will always
cost more than building you know the
same school in a place where land is
cheaper and so on and so forth so how
what is the end goal I mean if if you
had to redesign this from scratch how
flat would it be in terms of the outcome
you know how much should
we balance it and how much should we
recognize that some communities just
need to you know have a higher tax base
but also need to spend more to provide
the same level of Education
I'm just trying to understand you know
because you're saying we should move
this move in this direction how far you
know I think there are a lot of
variables that get you to that area we
want to be at some are non-money issues
some are like quality of the staff the
attitude of the teachers the attitude of
the administration the building the
leadership the supervision attitude of
the community aspiration of the family
the parents all those are issues which
are non-money issues
however we do know that it takes money
to have a chemistry lab
and many of these smaller schools don't
have that opportunity yet we are
expecting them to come out be prepared
to go to the next level of Niche
post-secondary education and so to
provide the opportunity for an adequate
education we're going to have to ensure
that we are providing those services
that we require them to have in those
schools I don't believe some of the
poorer communities have that happening
right now in fact when I met with the
principal in the building last night
from about five o'clock to seven o'clock
at night out in Warren
he was telling me how they are having to
do some extraordinary things just to
find the revenue to accomplish uh some
of their end goals and they're even
looking at maybe we need to consolidate
this school with the Wentworth Village
School which is a mile apart and we can
share instructions say they're looking
all these cost saving measures but
they're still not coming up to where
they need to be they're not competitive
and and us with that I would suggest
that we look at what these the dollars
in the fiscal capacity disparity Aid
that we once had and look at why did we
have that what did that committee back
in 2008 and 2009 do to recognize that
this is an absolute necessary thing we
didn't have all that stabilization we
have right now
that was taken out of that area taken
out a special ed and thrown into this
area here that we have stabilization we
put caps on it the Caps didn't work that
ended up with a lawsuit in the southern
part of the state uh we dropped down
four percent each year that didn't work
you know so where are we well we know we
got to fund more to these School
District how much I I I can't give you a
magic figure on that I think none of us
can do that but we do know that you know
when I talk to Super in the schools up
in SAU 23 she said I cannot be
competitive
with the level of salary being offered
to people down the river in Lime in
Lebanon and Hanover we have wonderful
art teacher boom two years later the
teacher's working for Hanover so the
consistency of program is not there uh
we need to help out a little bit in that
area and that's one where we could put
it I appreciate it I mean it's a high
it's a highly complex topic no question
about it and obviously this being the
finance committee we tend to focus on
the money because all the other things
are more of a local control local
scoreboard type issues in terms of
culture and non-monetary things
all I want to do is point out that
really
at the end of the day we cannot go all
the way to equal funding because that
would not recognize the different needs
of every Community too so it's it's just
a complex topic that I think we have to
keep striving to find the balance
there's a cultural needs in every
community and every Community is
different and we're not going to have
all people the same I got it uh however
if we're going to be asking our schools
to prepare kids at a certain level then
we're going to have to fund them to do
that
reasonably yes thank you yeah can I add
on to that just very very quickly so so
I and I think it's a very good question
um about how do you go about balancing
you know this the the
um the the
how to fund how the state should use its
precious resources when when funding
schools across the state do you fund all
the schools as you you just said or uh
or do you do you do you not do that and
um and you know I think we're sort of
we're sort of doing it both ways right
now we've got the interpretation that
representative Ladd said
that um that the state is responsible
for the first and last dollar of funding
an adequate education in all uh in all
uh for all school districts but at the
same time the first the the first those
first dollars actually come from swept
in all of these districts and for about
um 30-ish or so of those of these
districts including some that are
represented by people around the table
uh this afternoon uh they don't receive
any direct
um uh funding from the state they they
have their state property tax and they
don't receive any more so that's
essentially providing a um a means
threshold saying if you can pay for it
with this then then you're good if you
can't pay for it with this
Haverhill Hopkinton so many other
districts across the state the state's
coming in uh to make sure that you can
get to um to get to that adequacy number
so so you know what the governor's doing
in raising that adequacy number uh I
think is is is responsible in in in that
way uh but uh but I think it's it's
going to be a question that that as as
the Supreme Court you know it comes down
on on the Rand case and on the conval
case how does the state go about doing
that I think what the governor's
proposing here plus 529 is a terrific
interim step
um I I don't know when we're going to
hear back from from the the New
Hampshire Supreme Court but probably
over the next couple years and um and
and I think it will provide the
legislature with another opportunity to
hopefully revisit a school funding
formula that does not have stabilization
that does not have all these you know
things that work outside of the formula
uh in which to uh to hold it up that we
can actually develop a strong school
funding formula that works for the
students and the taxpayers you know
across um across the state independent
of things like stabilization and and
stuff like that thank you
for the question Joe yeah thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for being here uh
where do you propose I figure this is
going to cost about 41 million dollars
what do you propose this money is coming
from
so um what what's going to cost 41
million dollars yes 529.
the governor's formula I think
representative Bellows is I think she
came up with 39 million okay 36 million
but yes well if you what I did I took
the governor's whole harness column uh
total state aid and the current RSA plus
529 okay and the difference is 41 260
245 so
that's now I know we you know we
supplemented the swept uh just and
basically that was it ended up just
supplementing the uh property tax you
know for each what at about 27 yeah
which is 100 million versus the price
363 so
but that that that people pay our
districts paid that money and it was
just something back in yeah so represent
Petrie I think that's I think it's a
very good question and and obviously you
know the budget process is about
priorities and um and I guess the first
thing that I that I put out there is
that this money is already being being
paid for it's being paid for by local
property taxpayers so it's already there
these local properties are all of our
constituents and I'm sure we hear from
all of them uh or certainly many of them
that represent a very similar
um you know position what are you doing
about my property taxes what are you
doing about school funding
um so so it's already being paid for
through local property taxes
um with very different rates and and you
know the the person in a the family in a
in a um uh you know in a four hundred
thousand dollar home in Claremont is
paying about the same amount of real
property taxes as somebody in a four
million dollar home in Newcastle so so
it's all being paid for but at very very
different rates the um uh so so it all
comes down to priorities and and you
know we've we've got the the
commissioner I believe has has proposed
60 million dollars to uh to go to
education Freedom accounts what's the
priority is the priority 165 000
um public school kids and their families
and all the taxpayers that are
supporting them or is it the 3200
uh students with um with EFA accounts
only about a hundred of which actually
exited their Public Schools
um you know because of the existence of
of the program you know I think it's
gonna and that's just one obviously one
example of where the money could come
from I think representative Ladd maybe
suggested shifting some from the left
side to the right side
um and I don't want to you know I don't
want to get in I don't want to make this
a battle with uh with with efas but it
certainly no no and I yeah I'm not
trying to uh to do that but it could
become come out of base base adequacy
not go to the level the governor did yes
yes okay and and and for that it um
it would make a huge difference from for
schools that are struggling the most
um
and uh and you know I'm sure I'm sure a
you know detailed review could be but it
let's let's don't worry about that money
for a minute is the bill as it's
presented is this a good formula as you
look through it 529 yeah absolutely it's
it it starts at actually the The Rock
Bottom equalized valuation per pupil
um and uh I think it's 600 000 in the
you know equalized valuation and goes up
to 1.6 million dollars which is the
average equalized valuation so it is
absolutely getting that that lower
um 50 okay that's also a formula which
was developed by in 2018
by the task force that Karen umberger uh
ran uh so yes that's something we have
to look at but also you take a town like
uh Woodstock Lincoln area where their
Equis property evaluations may be up
there but they're medium family incomes
are down in the dump and and so you have
people living on land that are working
in an hourly wage
there's another Dynamic that we have to
look at when we're allocating these
resources it can't be strictly off of
equalized property valuation per pupil
and 529 includes that's 529 does that
okay yeah and it does that through
through looking at the percentage of the
concentration of students that um that
are part of the free and reduced price
lunch program not to get them free or
reduced price lunches but as a proxy for
low income and um and and a chunk of of
that of that state funding is associated
uh with um you know to provide grants
based on okay and finally with the the
governor's proposal here my my concern
is
I understand trying to whittle down the
stabilization
well the transition I don't want to see
a lot of gaps and holes from the
communities which are most needy that's
not going to help things and so we've
got to be careful that we're not having
a waterfall effect every now and then
for these these school districts we've
gone through that and that was very
unsuccessful
um and it would expedite it would
expedite any kind of legal actions that
we may be incurring in the future and I
would try to certainly try to follow
what the governor is providing us
because that is a good uh uh blueprint
for where we need to go but I would
tweak it though in the places that we're
encouraging you to look at so that we
can get those dollars to the communities
which actually have the most need for it
right now
okay other questions
anyone else that want to speak to 529
thank you very much thank you thank you
so the action on this would be to retain
this and discuss it in hb2 look can I
have them move by Joe Petri seconded by
very hot I got it all those in favor
okay
representative Luna you have our last
which one you want to do first 5 20 6 26
or 4 30.
um let's um
Let's do let's do 4 30 since I got that
so a little bit of History
um
4 30 came out of committee with no
recommendation
uh was tabled on the floor was taken off
the table and was voted ought to pass
and um and what the um what the bill
does is um is is
in the nutshell
um
um provides the policy that the
commissioner of Education stated when um
when presenting the education Freedom
account program to this committee uh and
the and the finance committee in the
Senate uh and the uh the education
Committee in the house which retained
the bill
um back back two years ago uh and the
the purpose was to provide
students from low-income families
who
who felt they needed an alternative to
their public school to have some money
from the state use essentially the state
adequacy Grant to um to open doors and
and provide them with access to these
alternatives
what what we've seen from from reports
from the Department of Education
indicate that closer to 80 percent of
the students who participate in the EFA
program were either already attending
were already attending a private school
or a home school prior to the uh
adoption of the of the EFA program so in
this case
the these families and these students
had already found alternatives to uh to
their Public School uh when when you
further take a look at the data and the
number of students that go to private
school and home school and you look at
um at the number of students that exit a
public school every year and have done
so for uh you know for many many many
many years and decades I mean students
leave public schools for a lot of
different reasons they may have a family
it may be sort of like a family history
going to private school it may be that
well I want to play football and my home
school doesn't do football and I want to
go to a private school and and play on
the team could be for a number of
different reasons uh and um and when you
sort of when you when you subtract out
students that uh that that for all these
reasons annually exit their their Public
School it really does not look like too
many of the 3200 students in the EFA
program
uh
you know really really really left
because of uh because of the
availability of of the state funding and
and I think that's a that's a real
concern because it's a real departure
from what the commissioner of Education
spoke about two years ago so what what
430 does is um is is it really says
you've got to be um you know it says
you've got to be a student in your um in
your public school and uh and it doesn't
require you to have any reasons for
leaving you don't have to have a certain
you know uh you know performance level
or your outcomes you can make your your
decision on your own it also doesn't
affect any students that are already in
the um the EFA program and there's been
some misinformation put out some
confusion uh on that but uh but the bill
uses very simple language only only
adding some new language on lines three
and four uh I actually we actually took
this language from some some amendments
that came up four years ago during the
work done on Senate Bill 193 uh that
would would require would have required
students to be currently attending their
public school before
um uh before applying to the uh to the
EFA program and um
you know that's what it does
questions
thank you
and thank you representative luno so
this bill is very simple it just simply
says that children have to be enrolled
in a public school setting before they
can apply for an EFA
yeah I mean that's that's exactly what
it says and and and it basically says
what I believe the commissioner of
Education was saying that the that the
the intent the purpose behind the
education Freedom account program is to
open doors for students who are in their
Public Schools seeking an old and a
private alternative thank you
push with you okay
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question my question is based
on my personal experience uh when I
lived in Waltham I started with I had
two girls you know five years and a half
apart by the time my eldest was in
fourth grade the public schools were
failing her completely we moved her to
uh you know
Catholic school that was the only
private school we could afford God knows
that stuff is expensive
according to your bill when my younger
kid
you know reached school age
they would have had to attend the same
public school that failed my eldest kid
for at least one year before they would
be allowed to leave I'm trying to
understand in a situation like this
which is one of the many you know
situations that could occur in this case
how is it in the public interest to
create this scenario where a parent who
already had a kid School failed them
they already know they don't want to go
to that school
what what is the public good coming out
of the forcing my second and third or
whatever other kids to attend the same
school that failed you know or could
their parents felt failed their first
kid sure no thanks very much for the
question and and and I think that's
that's why um
um why why there's an exception made
towards the end of line four or who is
entering kindergarten or first grade so
um so if you're if you're you know let's
say you're you're uh third or fourth
grade student who was struggling in or
or where their needs or her needs were
not being met in their public school
where their younger siblings uh become
uh eligible age eligible for
kindergarten or first grade they don't
have to matriculate into their public
school they can immediately apply for a
uh for an EFA follow up
thank you
I actually agree that that scenario
would not have applied to my particular
situation actually that's
I miss that part so okay that's why we
have cute I don't know but I appreciate
that point still similar situations
occur you know what would happen to
somebody who moves from out of state
already tried Public Schools moves into
New Hampshire now they get caught into
oh geez now you gotta go to public
schools in New Hampshire obviously it
wouldn't be the same exact Public School
but still again what's the policy
purpose of that with somebody who you
know already tried public schools in
another state comes here
why are we requiring them to attend yeah
no that's a that's a good question I
mean I I guess I would I I don't you
know
I
mean to start with New Hampshire has
some of the best public school and the
some of the best student outcomes in the
country so so I guess I would argue that
if you came from any other state
possibly even any other country that uh
that you and coming to New Hampshire you
may have some of the best public school
opportunities that are available
anywhere and um and and why not give
them a try
um uh honestly you know we we certainly
spend a lot of money uh on them uh New
Hampshire is um on average uh right in
the mix you know you know of things you
know in terms of per pupil spending of
the of our New England states
and um and you know we're our I think
our student outcomes are a little bit
behind Massachusetts which I think is
known for having some of the strongest
outcomes uh nationally
um uh you know if if people are moving
to New Hampshire
uh they probably got a reason and they
love our lakes and our ocean and our
Mount our mountains a lot of people tell
me in fact this is the first time I've
ever said this at uh or you know made a
made a made a statement like this in in
testimony we hear it all the time my
constituents tell me they like this or
they don't like that or something like
that or I hear this all the time what I
do here all the time
is that people move to New Hampshire
because of the schools I hear that
particularly from from people in
Hopkinton I hear that from my
constituents our constituents all the
time they move to New Hampshire because
of the schools
so just I lost last second last thing
as it happens I'm one of the people that
moved to New Hampshire and specifically
Windham because of the high quality of
the public school system our kids have
been in that forever I've served on the
school board I'm running again for the
school board we have an excellent you
know public school system
it's just that I recognize that not all
people moved to New Hampshire for the
same reason and I'm personally
uncomfortable with the thought of
telling somebody well you moved in now
you're gonna have to do this whether you
like it or not I think you make an
excellent case as to why the vast
majority of people coming in would not
need this to send their kids to public
schools and I would argue that you know
people who come in with different
thoughts you know should have a
different choice but I really appreciate
you clarifying and thank you for
the education Freedom account was a very
successful program
you have always been one of its
detractors and I think this is trying to
Harry
um so I I actually there was a a comment
made saying I've always been one of the
detractors I uh and I do want to address
that I think it's important I think
um
as all of us are are elected as all of
us are representing constituents not
just in our own communities but across
the state
and certainly the education Freedom
account program are paid those tax
monies are paid for by people all across
the state they're not paid for through
local property taxes business Enterprise
tax business profits tax Lottery we know
we know the smattering of sources on
there but but but I personally feel and
uh that I have a responsibility to make
sure that we put a program in place
that's responsible and has reasonable
guard rails if people don't feel that
way then I I don't know I mean I'm not
sure what what what constituents might
think about not being responsible and
not providing reasonable guard rails in
that chair over there last week two
weeks ago the governor said I think in
response to representative Heath's
question that that he would support
reasonable guard rails on the program
and to the extent this program was
presented as an opportunity for students
from low-income families who were
attending their public schools and are
looking for an alternative to that a
private alternative than then then House
Bill 430 fits the bill
sorry
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I want to know what the
purpose of this bill is
um thanks very much for the question uh
I I would say just just like what what I
just said for the um for the for the
program to um uh to be to be structured
to just as it was introduced and
presented two years ago uh by the
commissioner of Education to open doors
for students who are in their Public
Schools who needed a private alternative
and um and so it doesn't do anything
with the with the income requirement it
leaves that leaves that in place but um
but but to to provide an alternative to
students and students
um uh rather than their instead of their
public schools and so if you're if
you're in public school you can get an
alternative
um through the EFA uh uh uh to your
public school if you're just getting of
age into kindergarten or first grade you
can still
um uh seek out in an EFA got the
exceptions uh for that so so that's what
thank you
question
yeah thank you other states have efas do
other states have a similar guardrail
program like this or is this particular
to us no thanks thanks very much
um and um and and and thanks for
speaking with Me Kate Murray especially
after all my my comments on your your uh
your town I'm feeling a little isolated
here but
um
yeah but um but yeah other other um my
understanding is that other states do
have um uh limitations such as this and
and uh and what you what you do find in
those other states is that the
participation in the um in those um uh
uh education savings account or School
voucher or whatever the states want to
call them
um is much lower than than New
Hampshire's because it's not it's not
picking up you know it's not spending
eighty percent of its dollars picking up
students that were already in um in
private schools uh it's uh it's students
who are exiting their their public
school and and I think you know probably
deep down most of us would realize the
um
you know that that that that's a
different difficult call for most um uh
for most students that that they've got
to leave their friends leave their
teachers they've got to find a way to
get transported to to
um to either an uh a private school or a
homeschooling type type situation and
it's not a it's it's really not an easy
decision for kids that are already in in
um uh in in their Public Schools but for
students that have already students and
families that have already made the
decision that are Income eligible
they're already in a private school
environment and the state's saying here
you go here's a here's a
um you know five six seven eight
thousand dollar check
um that you can put towards your tuition
bills who wouldn't who wouldn't reach
out their hand and take that I mean it's
um it's it's it's
free money from the state uh free
taxpayer money from the state to pay uh
private school tuition bill and and uh
you know it was
you know you know so representative
Weiler I I certainly you heard me say
similar things well you heard me say
similar things I think
so
um uh two years ago when when I found it
very hard to believe that only four uh
private school students were estimated
to uh were estimated that we're going to
um take the the um the join the EFA
program and um and certainly we saw most
of the students come from these private
school environments and and I you know I
think that was sort of easy to see
then
thank you Mr chair quick follow-up you
were saying that you know giving money
to students who are already in private
school is you know retakes per money
from the state to pay a private tuition
bill
I cannot help but think about the many
towns that do exactly the same thing
with Pinkerton Academy and other private
schools
isn't it the duty of the state to
provide that adequate education funding
to you know every child shouldn't that
include
some form of adequacy support to parents
who have chosen a private school rather
than the public school
just in terms of the duty of the state
since we talk about so much sure no no
thanks thanks and that's a very good
question
um the um and I'm I'm I'm not I'm not
equipped here to be able to quote from
the the State Constitution and
oftentimes this part is misquoted and I
don't want to be one of those people
that misquotes it but but I do believe
our our the New Hampshire Constitution
requires all municipalities I'm sorry
requires um yeah all municipalities to
provide an education
um to all of for all of its children and
the state to do so through funding of
public schools and and the though those
two it's it's not in the Constitution as
sort of like one run-on sentence like I
just said but but it's got those it
contains those two specific uh
constitutional obligations
and and so no I don't think the um I
don't think the EFA program is anything
that's that falls out of our state
constitution as a requirement nor do I
think
um that Charter Schools fall out of our
state constitution as a requirement that
um uh and I've I have had conversations
with attorneys at the Department of
Education that says the state meets its
requirements constitutional requirement
um through through public school
districts
thank you I appreciate your answer
yeah
this bill would not be before us but for
a lack of attendance of sufficient
Republicans I would move in expedient to
legisly it's an attack on a successful
program
I hadn't said anything yet cut me a
little slack here
I did talk to our
senior member
and I said we would not take any votes
unless we have substitutes
so if if you would like to get get
substitutes or we can schedule the vote
okay
not a problem
so I would make the same motion on the
next bill
so we're ready to move to uh to 626 and
yeah so we're going to hold this and
take action at another time okay we're
not going to take action on that one
right now so and and
and and I I I I appreciate the chairs
Indulgence here particularly with
representative Heath in those prior
discussions and also I mean no
disrespect to any uh any member
um who may feel differently than me then
I about the the the
um if I could for just a sec I apologize
just to clarify we are done with the
discussion of 521 with no action and
we'll you know we're going to revisit it
right we'll revisit it but for now the
public hearing is done we are doing a
recess on it what where are we we're
recessing this on 529. sorry I need to
answer 4 30. 5 29 you took action on no
kidding yeah you got it yeah thank you
yeah I I'm good source recess okay no
thanks so now we're we're um we're going
to 626.
um six times same thing get moving
Expedia
excuse me mister
chair
I would give us for the same courtesy
that we give any other members
to present their bill to representative
luno it is not right nor is it fair not
to allow him to speak for the purpose of
this bill
representative thank you very much Mr
chair
um House Bill 626 is um uh is not a
housekeeping Bill and um and it's a bill
that that would change the uh it would
move the administration of the EFA
program from a private contractor and I
believe there's one that's been
authorized by the uh the executive
Council called the children's
scholarship fund it would move the
administration the the administration of
the program from that private contractor
to the Department of Education
and um and I'll I'll set the stage I'll
try to do it very very quickly on on on
this bill
um
uh it also came out of our committee
with uh with out recommendation and um
and and was was passed on the um the
house floor
the um
the
currently currently the the private
contractor and is administering a
program that uh in the first two years
of the program
um uh cost um cost the state
approximately
nine million dollars and in the second
two years of the program of the program
is costing the state I think closer to
to uh to 14 million dollars so 25
million dollars total in the first first
four I'm sorry first two years Sports
and first year of the program cost nine
million dollars second year of the
program 14 million dollars so so uh so
in the first two years of the program
costing uh taxpayers about 23 24 million
dollars
um for 3200 students the the Department
of Education obviously manages uh uh
over a billion dollars of State money
plus two billion dollars of um of local
property taxpayer money that is
appropriated to school budgets uh with
with total um program enrollment of
approximately 165
000 students so I would certainly say
that the Department of Education is
certainly equipped to be able to uh to
handle programs of this magnitude given
what they're doing right now but beyond
that
I think is um is is is something that is
is is a bit of a sort of a uh you know
is sort of financially
um
um inefficient in the in the EFA program
and and that's where the the private
contractor gets to retain 10 of the uh
of the state money that goes into the
program so in the first two years of the
program you know this this uh 23 million
dollars there they can retain uh 10 of
of that money I think they've testified
in our committee that that maybe they've
retained like nine percent of uh uh of
that and um and that's a lot of money
um you know uh over two million dollars
and where the program is going right now
where the the commissioner of education
has requested another 60 million dollars
over the next biennium so so close to 90
million dollars on the first four years
of the program uh that's um you know ten
percent is nine close to nine million
dollars and um and it would seem to me
and others that uh that the state may
able may be able to um to administer uh
the program in a um in a much more cost
efficient way some people have have said
well
10 percent
that's sort of along the same you know
in the same ballpark as to what Public
Schools administrative costs are you
know for the sau's and and uh and
administration but keep in mind this
isn't a pro the EFA is not a program
that that administers education it
channels taxpayer dollars uh to be
directed where the parents you know
where the parents wish them to be
directed to an organization such as uh
such as a Catholic school or another
private school or or uh to uh to to to
to pay those those costs and those costs
that they're that this money is paying
for already include a 10 to 15 percent
um you know cost associated with
administering that program so we're very
quickly uh turning you know State money
into something that 10 comes off here
and then it goes to a private school
another 15 percent comes off here and uh
and so the the uh you know the purpose
the intent behind House Bill 626 is to
um to have the um have the Department of
Education manage this program and um and
uh be much more more efficient in terms
the use of taxpayer dollars that are
used for efas and um and direct more of
those EFA dollars to um uh to uh
providing alternatives for students as
opposed to funding a private contractor
okay questions
and thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
um I am I don't know if I'm a co-sponsor
of this I guess not but I am a supporter
of this bill as a former Deputy
Commissioner I am really concerned about
over 60 million dollars being
overseen by uh private organization I
have no complaints about the
organization per se I simply feel that
when we're dealing with taxpayer money
I would prefer
I would like an organization that has a
record of dealing with millions of
federal dollars local dollars our
taxpayer dollars
to be overseen by the Department of
Education and the Department of
Education has a great reputation they
have done it well I mean one of the
questions that I asked the governor was
would he be in favor of it being
overseen by the Department of Education
and he did not have a problem with it
but I really and truly am concerned as I
believe you are about the amount of
money being overseeing taxpayer money by
a private organization thank you
other questions
thank you Mr chair um
obviously you know there are
complexities here again right
one of the things that I heard you say
was you know 60 million dollars
scheduled for the next biennium 10
percent is a lot of money and of course
it would if there would actually be a
need to spend six million dollars to
disburse you know
60 million dollars my understanding
though is that a lot of the initial
costs were due to you know the overhead
of setting the program up and the
operational costs are expected to be
much lower going forward have you you
know examined those projections or did
you look at those numbers in making the
case for this bill
or would it be just you know you just
prefer the doe to do it regardless of
whatever the cost of the private
organization would be sure no thanks
thanks very much for the um for the
question
um yeah I I would say that's that's
that's a that's a fair question but the
um the the the statute in 194f doesn't
say that the private organization gets
to retain 10 during the formative
startup years and then one and a half
percent ongoing it says 10 for every
year and uh and I think that should
raise concerns to uh to all of us who
have fiduciary UH responsibilities and
certainly uh financial responsibilities
to our to our constituents and how their
tax dollars are being used and um and so
that's really what sparked I think my
interest in um uh in in filing this um
this legislation uh uh was was really to
to you know have have this program uh
administered as uh through the
Department of Education as they
administer so many other programs that
um that are um sort of uh
sometimes directly related sometimes
adjunct uh related to our to our uh
Public School Systems yeah thank you and
just to quickly follow up
yeah the statute says 10 percent but
then there is hb2 so then there is hb2
correct correct statutes are a bit
flexible when it comes to the finance
committee or the other way around so you
know those things can be addressed if
you know that's the direction that
committee feels so it's appropriate I'm
not saying that I know what direction a
committee wants God knows I'm a freshman
my other question is we were just
talking earlier when we were going over
you know the uh
oh I got whichever of the bills and I'm
a co-sponsor of it that was dealing with
a special education in the DHHS you know
episode of treatment bills we had a long
discussion and one of the things that
the HHS was saying was that they were
essentially using all outside
contractors to manage this for
flexibility and you know because they
can just get exactly what they need and
there is there are many times when there
is significant relays overhead in using
a third party to perform certain
services and also relating to this to
the comment uh from representative Heath
on you know the doe has a lot of
expertise on dealing with federal
dollars of Education we were just saying
that this doesn't really administer
education and federal dollars it's just
a simple conduit to meet eligibility for
a certain Grant and distribute the funds
it's a much simpler job than the overall
Doe
why wouldn't you know why why is it that
again we are looking at doe when maybe
you know there are options to
save money and use a dedicated third
party which of course could be put out
to bid I mean nobody should have you
know a Eternal contract but why not put
it out to bid it's a simple job and you
know maybe do it for less and don't you
know achieve the same results yeah I
think that's a very very fair way to um
to look at I would not have an objection
to to uh to finding a more cost
efficient way of of doing that I you
know it's just you know I wouldn't
necessarily want to want to be
duplicative to something we're already
funding through the the the state um the
state's um Department of Education and
and just looking at at the number of
students involved here the the state
it's it's clearly within the scope of
their their capabilities one very quick
follow-up that was a question I wanted
to ask earlier and I should have maybe
at that time
you um were talking about the number of
dollars you know that was spent in the
first two years and we are all familiar
with the numbers
were you mentioning those just to show
how the um you know costs exceeded the
original forecast or was there a concern
that you know had uh the same contract
being managed by Doe fewer funds would
have been this fewer students would have
been approved
um
so so I'll try to answer that question I
I I think the the fact that the forecast
presented two years ago was so far
removed from reality
um should raise concerns to everybody
and and it should want it it should it
should compel all of us to try to
understand how those forecasts could be
so far off and um and honestly that was
one of the things that led to the
conclusion of uh of filing House Bill
430 the prior the last bill that um that
that that we had but um but uh but when
when when now taking a look at at rather
than the forecasts of number of students
taking a look at the the forecast of
dollars you know there's there's one
thing when we talk about you know 10 of
139 000 which is what the financial
Force forecast was
two years ago I mean ten percent is
still ten percent don't get me wrong but
but I'm not gonna lose sleep over
fourteen thousand dollars in a in a you
know on a I don't know what we're at you
know uh you know billions uh state
budget 12 billion dollar state budget
um uh but uh but when we're when we're
talking about you know 60 million
dollars over the next biennium yeah can
we do better does 10 10 really adding up
here so thank you I really appreciate it
yeah thank you I guess the phrase has
been used that this is essentially a
pass-through sort of a administrative
process and 10 million dollars seems
like an awful lot of money for a pass
through
activity
um
I can Envision an individual person
being able to manage the number of
students and passing through this this
money if it if that's all that's
involved
um can you respond to that and also can
you ask if Deo has come back to say that
yeah we can you know we could create a
position it would be far less expensive
than 10 million dollars and do they have
a sense of how much less it would be
so I thank thank you very much
representative Murray I don't have uh an
answer to
um to that question uh but um but we
have seen
um requests
um uh from the department and and bills
you know filed over the last um several
years to uh to for instance for example
hire a um you know a staff member at the
uh at New Hampshire education to um
to oversee the um the chartered public
school
um uh Charter Public Schools uh in New
Hampshire so it's one one person to do
that uh I don't know what the total
enrollment of Charters are I think we
have about 30-ish so so there could be
somewhere around three thousand
it's not that hot yeah but but it's
somewhere in the it's it's not 165 000
and and it's not 300 it's somewhere you
know uh certainly closer to I think the
size of the EFA uh program so so it's
not unreasonable to have one person
potentially oversee this and have that
oversight in the state and available to
us more readily yeah I think that's I
think that's a reasonable uh reasonable
thing and um and possibly
um uh have um have a third party that uh
that handle you know much like
businesses
uh contract with um with with you know
have Merchant accounts for to be able to
accept credit cards and they pay you
know a two percent
um you know fee or one and a half
percent fee uh uh on on that uh that
maybe there's something like that but
it's it's certainly far less than I mean
it's not even close to the 10 that uh
I just asked one final question
um
if the department were to take over the
administration of the efas
would it be possible for them to
contract with the current agency
for which the department then would
oversee hopefully there'd be an RFP and
then they would oversee the contract
and on that basis would that make a
difference
yeah thanks I I mean there's certainly
nothing in this nothing in 626 that
would prevent that from from happening I
think that would be a conversation that
that the the contractor would have to
have with the uh with the Department to
see if that makes Financial Cent
business sense uh for them uh and and
yeah I I think that would be something
that certainly could be considered
but right now if we pass if since 26
passes it's not funded
it's not I
I didn't I mean I
looking through this bill that doesn't
have any funding methods there's no
appropriation in this in this in this
bill uh this is strictly on the policy
side
um of uh of the department administering
the program that there's you know I
think there's another
um there's another piece of this that's
that's you know worth you know
trying to figure out what you know for
for the in the first year of the program
um 2021
uh
I think it was close to nine million
dollars of of taxpayer money this is the
report that we get oh okay you know I
thought you were looking at this no no
no no no no no this is this is the
report that that we got from the uh from
the private contractor and um and I'm
not even sure what to what to tell from
from the report how how useful it is uh
one of the one of the one of the things
that that I think we would have better
oversight as a legislature is if the um
if the Department of Education were to
what were to have the details not
looking for student specific stuff I
don't think that's we we don't get that
from from the Department of Education
now we certainly don't get it from HHS
you know that's not the that's not where
where we're at but um but making sure
that um
that that the program's being run
responsibly that uh that there's no uh
uh evidence of fraud as has been seen in
other states and the commissioner of
Education said it on WMUR several weeks
ago
um uh that that other states have
experienced fraud
um in the program and uh and we really
just don't have uh safeguards in the um
in the uh statute right now to uh to
help prevent that so this is one of
those guardrail bills to uh uh to help
prevent that and um and there's there's
a couple others too that um you know
that would additionally be able to to
help prevent fraud in the program and
I'm not and I'm not making any
accusations of of fraud I don't have any
evidence to say those been fraud other
than that that this has happened in
other states and I don't have any reason
to believe that New Hampshire would be
be somehow magically immune to that
since the 10 is already being funded out
of the appropriation to the EFA wouldn't
this position also be funded out of the
appropriation for the EFA in terms of
the funding it's not that we would have
an additional funding forward it's just
the funding would come out of the EFA
appropriation like it is now it would
just go to
I would have to say it would have to
appear somewhere to say that
well you could I mean that I think
that's I representative Murray I think
you've got a good point there that that
the current statute calls for 10 to fund
the uh the administration of the program
and that it could be taken out of those
funds or it could be taking out of other
operating funds that the that the
department you know uh requests and has
appropriated so I I mean I think that's
you know this is like I said 676 I think
is a policy Bill and um and and finance
Finance Finance is finally I think it's
a great way to look at it so any other
questions
but I want to recess this until we have
a full committee great thank you very
much Mr chair members of the committee
that's all right
so we will we can be so briefly we we
did schedule a budget work session for
now so we are permissible to talk about
issues I will say the Department of
Education had some information on a
couple of the earlier bills that they
wanted to just share before they left
today so Market asked or just a moment
so I for the record marketing hello
Bureau of school finance department of
education I just have a memo I know I
know you've done a lot of work on a lot
of different adequacy bills today I just
want to run through
um a few key things that I just want to
point out that was not did not come up
um so just to discuss a little bit about
the adequacy estimate process a lot of
numbers are going around
um sometimes when we do an adequacy
estimate we don't do the full quality
control so sometimes the number just
gets thrown out there and really what I
think the when doing school funding
formula you have a lot of different
bills in front of you as you sort of
narrow in on an idea that this committee
is really interested in because you've
got a lot of different bills that you're
looking at
um uh Mickey will likely just throw
numbers out there and the department
might just throw numbers out there we're
not going to fully quality control them
as you sort of hone in on the policy you
like that will give us as you tell
Mickey and I it will give us more time
to really vet those numbers out and make
sure we're really confident in the
number you're going to put into your
budget so I have a little disclaimer on
some of these numbers
the only things I'd like to bring up is
um House Bill 272 just pointing it out
um I think it was in the fiscal this
Bill had a fiscal known it was a man did
the price tag has now dropped down to
4.9 million so it's a little cheaper
than as it was introduced just pointing
out that this does not include the
virtual Learning Academy Charter School
if you wanted to include that into the
bill it would cost about 1.2 1.9 million
a year just pointing that out to fund
vlax
to give them the same additional Grant
Aid you're going to give a non-v-lax
charter so just pointing that out making
sure it's known with House Bill 529
representative fellows bill as we talked
about uh the bill as introduced was 95.8
Million
um if you were to merge it into the
governor's proposal as the governor's
presented uh his proposal
um I think the cost is I plugged that
number into our spreadsheet 36 million
and that's because a lot of that
additional ladies getting eaten up by
the hold harmless so it's netting
against the Holt harmless
making the hold harmless Grant smaller
so making it cheaper on that end but
increasing eight over here
so the the cost there is 36 million
rough number again disclaimer out there
um the they're also Senate Bill uh not
Senate Bill sorry House Bill 529 was
amended and the department hasn't had a
lot of time to assess this amendment but
it added an accountability requirement
to this grant so similar to the
accountability requirement that's in
Senate Bill 420 uh last year's last
session that added an accountability
requirement requirement to the
extraordinary needs Grant House Bill 529
also adds an accountability requirement
I think I have a question from
representative right I'm looking at this
uh handout we had in the governor's aide
after hold harmless was 653 million and
change and uh the current RSA plus 529
is 694. that difference is 41 million
how where I I'm not I'm having a hard
time understanding what you're saying
I'm saying 36 million and I actually
have not investigated what that
discrepancies discrepancy is it could be
an excess sweat thing it could be there
could be another aspect of it um I did
my math really quick you're doing quick
math as well one of us is both of us
could be wrong both of us could not both
of us can't be right it's the aggregate
I mean you know I'm not you know five
million hell what the hell is five
million yep I mean when you're doing
this much money it's it's not a big I
think we're hand grenade closer yeah
yeah yeah
that's right Army talk so if you if you
really like 529 and you want to blend it
into the governor's formula you like the
governor's formula like 529
um we're talking in the ballpark of 40
million um have Mickey really look at
the numbers carefully and Mickey can
work with the department and we can
really become confident in the numbers I
just so added two columns to the
spreadsheet for the governors and I just
threw in representative fellows numbers
and and I probably didn't go through a
full method I was doing it quickly
because I was doing a lot of estimates
here uh Mickey was uh Mickey was curious
about how all these bills would match
with the governor's uh formula so I did
some quick math or some quick
spreadsheet moving around could be an
error in my spreadsheet
um it could be a four million dollar
error easily but does happen
um but just giving you ballpark figure
we're talking about those numbers I
don't know the exact reason why we have
discrepancies
um another thing I want to point out
about House Bill 529 uh the the
accountability component so just looking
at some of the language about the with
the accountability amendment that was
added there seems to be a technical
error for example that Amendment seems
to reference RSA 194 41A that's
um an error it should be I believe it
should be RSA 198 so I think there's a
technical error there another potential
technical technical error with the
accountability plans is
there's the extraordinary needs Grant
which requires an accountability plan
under current law then there's 529 as
amended that incl that also requires an
accountability plan but those are now we
have three grants but I'm not sure how
many accountability plans we have do we
have one accountability plan do we have
two accountability plans or do we have
three accountability plans so I would
like the committee to make that clear if
the department were to implement
529 as amended I need to know how many
accountability plans I'm uh we are going
to require of the districts so um could
a district submit one accountability
plan if they receive all three grants
additional F and raid
fiscal capacity disparity a and
extraordinary needs Grant do they submit
one accountability plan or do they
submit three or do they submit one that
covers the additional fnr Aid and the
fiscal capacity disparity just just
clarify that if that's the if that's the
um another thing with accountability
plans this is just I'm just alerting you
we've now we've now done accountability
plans for one year we did accountability
plans for Extraordinary needs Grant some
of the things we're learning
um I probably had about 40 phone calls
with school districts when the
accountability plan uh law was passed
um there's a lot of confusion out there
adequacy is designed to be an
unrestricted aid program
to think of that if you were to make
adequacy restricted you would need to
redesign the adequacy grant because I
pay it on a distribution basis I don't
pay it on restricted grants are based on
a reimbursement basement so for me to
make it restricted I would have to say
show me with documentation that you
spent it for this service if you show me
the documentation it was spent for the
service I'll release the money that's
how almost all grants work adequacy is
not designed to be a restricted Grant we
don't have the staff to make it a
restricted Grant it's always designed to
be unrestricted and essentially
underwrites whatever the school
districts are providing they're
providing by law inadequate education
and adequacy underwrites that so
basically is uh It underwrites Whatever
the taxpayers have to pay so it's always
used as a a support to the taxpayers the
taxpayers are required to implement an
adequate education inadequacy just backs
backfills that so that's how the program
is designed
there's a disturbing Trend where we see
the school enrollments going down but we
keep adding more employees for
non-teaching staff is there some
accountability for all this increase in
employees
is that does the 25e take care of that
or so there's there's uh no uh there's
no requirement in RSA or sorry not RSA
House Bill 529 that districts account
for declining enrollment and how they
manage their resources in the face of
declining enrollment there's no mandated
requirement in that accountability plan
no the puzzling thing is why do you keep
adding employees while you're losing
enrollment
that's that is a there's
um I don't have I'm not really I don't
really look at the employment data but
um there is declining enrollment for
sure and there's increased cost for sure
and some of it is a non-teaching staff
so I think maybe we need something in
legislation to say give us an
explanation
that would be um that you could go that
um another thing with uh accountability
plans is
um
once you start dealing with assessment
data student assessment data that is
private information so if we have
schools discussing about particular
classrooms small schools and particular
classrooms where they would like to
approve outcomes
we have an issue with making that
transparent because that could
potentially disclose the um the the
educational performance of a student so
it is a challenge with accountability so
just making you aware of that that is a
natural challenge when it comes to
accountability so accountability through
transparency it has to be done in this
rolled up basis it can't really be done
on this granular basis because then you
risk identifying the students
educational performance so just a
challenge to keep you in mind as you
think about accountability I think we
are having that issue when we tell
districts to give us your accountability
plan and then they give us an
accountability plan that we basically
can never be make public because it
would potentially disclose the
educational performance of a student so
just something we've come across to
we're one year into implementing
extraordinary needs Grant accountability
plans and that's
um some of the things we're learning
let's see how to see if I have any other
things I want to mention I think I'm
covering all the bases here and you have
I have my memo I'm going to bring up um
uh Kelly Rambo in a second
um
last thing on House Bill 540 uh this the
changes to this uh sped differential Aid
uh representative lad's Bill to put into
three buckets
three things about our one thing about
that is that requires a whole new data
set for us to merge with our existing
adequacy data set
it's not impossible we have the data but
it might be unreasonable to ask the
department to
for you to pass this in law make this go
effective July 1 and then we have to
scramble all summer long to make sure
the data is reliable and blended into
our existing systems we we can probably
do it because you ask us to do something
we'll get it done
um you know via law we'll comply with
the law but it's a it's a heavy ask for
our department to make this in the
fiscal year 24 formula so it would make
more sense for you to make it in the
fiscal year 25 formula then we have a
little bit more time to work with our
data processes to make sure the sped
data can come in exactly how it needs to
come in we have time to work with the
calculation to make sure we don't make
an error because what happens in when
you pass the budget we have to Now set
adequacy it's a new adequacy formula if
you do a new adequacy formula we have to
set it in fiscal year 24 and that number
is going to be used to set tax rates and
so any error we make between July 1 when
you pass the budget and not in September
1st when we start using revenues for
taxes if we don't fix it or resolve it
or we make an error basically taxes will
be messed up so this is a little bit
complicated so we'd like to have a
little bit of leeway to look at this
data and blend it into our systems for
the fiscal year 25 formula so just a
request for me personally so I don't
um and then also uh
bringing in 540 I think the the as
introduced it's 19.8 million rolling
into the governor's formula for fiscal
year 25
12.17 million uh Mickey has all these
numbers so um as you kind of pick and
choose which formulas you like don't
like
um that's the option you'll have if you
choose to roll it into the governor's
formula
um I want to talk a little bit about
House Bill 601 I don't know if Kelly can
come up
um House Bill 601 is Medicaid direct
cert
um so as you know house Medicaid direct
cert involves our food and nutrition
program I'm going to talk about how it
impacts adequacy and then I'll uh Kelly
Rambo talk about how it impacts uh the
food and nutrition program
so a couple things about Medicaid direct
cert
as we've talked about
this will increase our fnr numbers by an
unknown amount if we start directly
certifying students for fnr using the
Medicaid data this will have an unknown
cost to adequacy ranging from between 22
million to 42 million in fiscal year 26
if everything goes according to plan
meaning you enact a Medicaid direct cert
we uh uh go through the USDA processes
we get that we do the data sharing with
DHHS everything gets implemented
a cost of around 22 million to 42
million I think it's on the lower end I
think it's gonna be closer to 22 million
um I think the 42 million is an inflated
number because right now Medicaid
enrollment is inflated because no one's
been kicked off the rolls because of the
pandemic
the bill House Bill 601 as it was
amended by education also added an
opt-out provision
so
um
this would the way looking at six House
Bill 601 as amended it looks like it
would allow a family at the application
Level to opt out
an application for SNAP an application
for TANF an application for Medicaid any
direct cert any direct cert uh
application all right sorry any director
program so that'd be TANF snap and then
potentially Medicaid they could opt out
at the application Level and so
currently that doesn't happen so but the
law the house bill 601 if it became law
DHHS would have to implement that and
based on the way I read 601 is they
would have to implement it immediately
so there would be an opt-out provision
in
uh starting in fiscal year 24 or fiscal
year 24 meaning when the budget passes
if you were to add this as amended that
would impact 25 adequacy and what I
don't know about the opt out is and just
just alerting you is some people I
imagine would opt out and if they do opt
out that might hurt the f r numbers and
if it hurts the fnr numbers it would
hurt school funding
um uh decrease school funding I have no
clue who would opt out
it might be zero people if it's zero
people then every number is your look
all the numbers you're looking at would
be
would be fine I guess if someone does
opt out the fnr numbers would decrease
potentially by an unknown amount I have
no clue
um so
I
the chair is it okay
I do not believe and I remember what we
what we were trying to do today was just
give the doe and Health and Human
Services the authority to proceed to
apply
um we did not include this amendment
in that bill
so I'll have two amendments drafted yes
one that will be only section one yes
and one that will have section one as
well as the data sharing section so the
committee can choose which direction you
want to go uh when we have those
amendments for a later work session
right thank you
and and as you look at those two options
and you decide if you do
um
um I don't know the intent of I wasn't
there when the amendment occurred
um there might have been an intent to
have the data sharing sync up with when
Medicaid director would go into effect
but
that's not what the amendment I don't
think that's what the amendment does so
just something to consider if you want
to sync up the opt-out with when
Medicaid enrolls or do you want to have
the opt-out be a standalone process that
DHS would Implement as soon as it
becomes effective so um something for
you to think about I don't know if it
was I don't know if that exactly was
discussed with how sad so I'm just
alerting you if that's something
something you might need to consider
uh those that doesn't exist in the
current programs correct they don't they
don't have any opt-out um DHS has given
testimony that they don't have any
opt-out
um
program that they're doing so uh uh I
think if 601 as amended is not passed I
I don't know what they would do I think
they would continue their program as
implemented meaning no opt-out so if you
go to yeah just have a conversation with
you they were here earlier but they had
to leave DHHS people
um but that's yeah that's what I think
yep
hi Kelly Rambo
um Bureau administrator for nutrition
and wellness at the Department of
Education I just wanted to speak to that
at the local level so there is the
opportunity for parents
um for the freedom reduced program if
they do are identified that they are
eligible they can opt out of that at the
local level currently already
okay
together
so now
um to discuss a potential uh budget
amendments that would need to be made or
that the department has relative to
Medicaid direct cert so you have a
little table here
so adequacy no impact on fiscal year 25
unless you want to make assumptions
about opt out and fnr numbers which I
can't make
the state meals program so we do have uh
General funds that go towards State
meals uh
and so we estimate that to be if
Medicaid director were to be enacted a
hundred and eighteen thousand dollars in
general funds so there's a particular
line item uh Kelly can work with with
Mickey as far as getting you the
information you need if you do to
Medicaid direct cert we think there will
be an increase in timeout timeout yep
uh we were we weren't getting this far
down the path were we you had too much
I think you're way ahead of where we are
okay where we are was to
authorize
application for a prototype
of the program okay you're you're
solving the problem here or giving us
information that we're not even ready to
you're building a bridge for us we're
not ready to cross
and I'm trying to lighten your load a
little bit and that's and that's fine
um uh we're just trying to give you
information and be proactive and I
understand uh I understand uh you have a
lot of information coming your way and
you're trying to build the puzzle pieces
that is your budget uh if you were to
give us the authorization we would
attempt to apply immediately if we
attempted to apply immediately
ah and we were accepted which we believe
we would be accepted
um there's cost associated with that so
by giving us the authority to apply we
see it as a mandate to apply to the
program meaning we would
meaning we would act immediately to
pilot avail
may not be for a couple of years
um agriculture has to make that
available and as of yet I do not believe
they have am I you'd know better than I
that is correct uh for some reason they
have discontinued the pilot right with
39 states in the program so we don't
think that they'll hold that we're
making a lot of assumptions here and a
lot of guesses we don't think they'll
we think they'll we we speculate that
they'll remove that hold on the program
because I don't know why they would run
a pilot program for 10 years and then
suddenly discontinue it we speculate
that they'll
uh remove the discontinuing of that
program and if they remove that
discontinuing of the program and this
601 is introduced in the budget we would
begin our work to apply to the program
um immediately within our deadline the
deadline is if they enact if they bring
the program back which we speculate that
they will again a lot of assumptions and
contingencies here we would move forward
with
applying for the program and then we
would be moved forward with implementing
the program if we were accepted into it
and just all of those mechanics have
costs whether you want to address those
costs in the budget we think it makes
sense to address in the budget you could
you could come up with a different
vehicle to address them uh but they will
have impacts Financial impacts if all
those pieces fall into place would it
help you if we
inserted in uh what we want to the
authorization that we want to give you
that we could say we would not expect
the department to apply until
2025 if in fact it became available
so that we're giving you time I just I
believe that ultimately the U.S
department of Agriculture will
eventually kind of say this is going to
be for everybody I'm assuming
um if you want to go into it but we
don't know
um and it could come back again they're
just I hate to have us lock up money
that we don't know about
whether or not this is even going to be
possible so we simply want to give you
authorization but we don't want you to
knock yourself out doing all this other
stuff when you don't need to Yeah we
actually already have
kind of have authorization there's no
statute or state law preventing us from
applying to the program so we actually
already have authorization what 601 is
is a policy decision by the legislature
so if you want to make the policy
decision that we don't want you to enter
right away we would like you to enter at
a specific point in time
601 is
there's nothing in state like I said
nothing in state law preventing us from
applying to this program
now we just know it has Financial
impacts so we've decided to make it
we're not going to make the call on if
we enter the program the legislature is
going to make the call on if we enter
the program so we read 601 the
department interpret 601 is a mandate
not an author not only an authorization
but not only the green light but a
but if you want to change that mandate
and change the language and communicate
with us in different ways through state
law that's that's possible what we're
looking at I'm just looking at your
columns are 30 30 to 54 million dollars
to Mary's Point that's a lot of that's
tying up a lot of
budget for
go ahead so yeah so that is correct but
that's fiscal year 26 so it's kind of um
the next committee is also it's 11
million so so no no that's that's
Federal money
um and that's
I made a lot of assumptions to get to
that number uh Mickey has in my fiscal
note now and he'll publish it with a lot
of assumptions that's potentially
increase in federal money
um choose it's gonna likely supplant
local school lunch Revenue Local School
breakfast Revenue the only cost to the
state general fund is approximately
118k in the state meals program and then
also the department would be to to make
these changes to enact these changes we
have some Contracting expenses we would
like added to our budget to amend some
of our software systems and then also
Kelly to implement this program Kelly
has a staffing position she would uh
request and so that's all detailed here
so we're just making you aware of if you
go forward with this there are Financial
costs as far as implementing it
um and also the way we would with the
way we understand 601 is that we would
go forward with it and you have those
costs
okay
all right and that's that's all I wanted
to get across if you have any questions
for for Kelly or myself about about
these costs and about any technical
questions I've given you a lot of
information and I know you've had a long
day so I appreciate you taking the time
to tear us out
I appreciate your
efforts
so
if we have your numbers and so if we go
forward with it it looks like we're
talking a couple hundred thousand
dollars
that's correct to me it's not the
millions that I glanced down here no uh
yeah that's sorry because I have to
follow the fiscal no process and all
revenues on the table I know you mostly
care about the general funds
can I just add when Karen and I began
talking about
we we had a committee that came together
to talk about
um adequacy funding and then we came up
with the fact that we didn't have
very good numbers on freedom reduce they
were inadequate
um so we wanted to come up with an
adequate measure of a true number of
children in the state of New Hampshire
that were free and reduced and out of
that whole conversation came direct
Medicaid certification that's where all
this came from and that's our purpose in
seeking was this was to get better
numbers for you to work with ultimately
and
feed more kids really
um so
we want to go for well speaking for me
we want to go forward with this
but would it help if we inserted a date
further out for you so you don't like
this summer you won't have to do this
all summer I just don't want you to get
stuck having to do a lot of work when in
fact we won't even be eligible until uh
26. we we wouldn't begin the work we
wouldn't for we're not going to start
the work now
all right Kelly has to do the most
substantial work so I'll let her speak
to it
foreign
thank you um and like you stated before
that currently there is no opportunity
at this moment right now there's no
pilot program
um it's not in place at this moment
um there have been talks at the USDA
level that there will be another pilot
um they're looking at September possibly
to have that open
um and it was due the the pilot was
closed um excuse me due to the RFP that
was put out it was put out for a number
of years and obviously those close
um so we wouldn't be able to actually do
any work on it until the new RFP came
out so we would then have to do that go
through the application process
and that I believe was about a year
timeline
um before that whole thing could be done
and submitted and approved if if
approved by USDA and then the
implementation would would take
um after that so we would need to um we
would need a good amount of time to do
the application process which is why I
had requested the additional funds for a
position our consultant to be able to do
that
so
with the authorization
that we are providing for you you would
like the funds requested
that's correct and then everything would
I mean
um so so it's contingent upon we're just
assuming the USDA is going to open it
back up
um if if they don't open it back up and
we don't have to do any of the work
we're not going to spend the money
especially
some of it's set up in state law
um but yes we would like the funds to to
implement the program assuming well our
predictions will all play out the way we
think they'll play out
all right
you have a question
thank you just a quick question you said
that you see this bill as a mandate to
go ahead and apply for direct
certification when looking at the you
know uh B language and that's what I'm
trying to understand it says Department
of Education participation in the
demonstration projects to evaluate
direct certification it doesn't seem to
be
guiding you to
you know entering direct certification
just in the specific pilot program I'm
trying to understand where the uh you
know legal mandate is because my reading
doesn't
agree with that but I could be missing
something wouldn't be the first one or
the last time no I I think you're you're
looking into the details of the language
and I think I think your reading is I
think your reading is fine
um uh I I think your interpretation is
fine
um the way we interpret this is this has
been an ongoing conversation we've had
with uh the former chairwoman umberger
about this
um exact
uh uh uh this language exactly this
position we're in the department has
full authority to enter this program
unilaterally without legislative without
legislative oversight or sorry without
legislative enactment so
this is really
what the activity you're doing we see
this as legislative intent whether it
really is legislative intent or not or
whether the language truly does say you
it says Xiao which is a strong word but
it says shall participate and so just
the way we interpret that we can
disagree about interpretation but the
way the department interprets that is I
appreciate your point for the record I'm
one of the people who didn't exactly
vote for this but
even if it does become law my reading
would be that this is talking about
direct about the you know pilot and not
about you know the direct participation
in the Pro the particip participation in
the direct enrollment
but I do hear you when you say that you
already have that Authority without
legislation I appreciate that
can I just add
that you do
but the commissioner
has insisted that he has a legislative
reason to do it
otherwise he didn't want to move forward
and that came from
representative umberger and our
committee when we were working together
this is why we went forward with 601
okay
I think we're all set I know we're worn
so we'll adjourn and reconvene tomorrow
caucus
so just just for the committee's uh
knowledge here we did recess fourth
house bill 430 and and Hospital 626 the
2f EFA bills which means technically
they're open but I don't know if you
wanted to have me schedule something
again another work session in this the
calendar or just if you wanted to make a
plan of when you wanted to do those
bills
wait until the regular members come as
party I could I could I could just
schedule a work session Friday at one on
those okay if that works and then just
do them Friday at one or ten I mean
whatever why don't we do them a ten ten
that's fine I'll be here well we can do
it at one
I I had scheduled a budget work session
for 10 but I think as Janet hasn't done
it yet so I can probably do the bills at
10 and then 10 30 for a budget work
session then we can do work after if we
want to
yeah
you're not losing so far
foreign